okay we're ready to go ahead with the
executive session today so we need to
have all our committee members
back
okay so uh those in the committee are
aware of what we have coming up in front
of us here for the next week and a half
uh and for the public as well uh this
committee had 107 bills this this year
not including Senate bills that's more
than any committee ever ever had in the
history of this
house and we have completed all 107
hearings of those 107 we have 34 bills
we have not yet
exec and and some of us are just getting
fatigued on all
this not some all of us all of us are
but I want to let you know what's coming
up in the next week and a half here so
you can put it down in your calendar
because it's not in the blue calendar
yet but it it is uh it was designed last
night around
11:00 um on the 11th of March that's a
Monday the we we have the exact session
today this being Wednesday Thursday
we're in full session Friday we're not
here I have to be at a trustee meeting
in at at keing State College that day so
on Monday the 11th we're starting out
with a hearing on HB
1015 that's a non-gain amendment that
which going to be hearing that hearing I
have found for about an
hour following that at 10:00 through
noon time we have six bills dealing with
Cooperative school districts or for with
merging of saus or with how we elect
people to school uh to the boards of
these particular organizations we're
going to have a work session on these
bills number of folks right here have
not been involved with that in the past
and we'll be amazed to see all the
different agreements which we have for
co-ops and the very different agreements
they all are and how some co-ops don't
even have
agreements and so there's a lot to this
and so we want to have everybody up to
speed to some degree on where we're
going with all this uh in past years the
co-ops have really taken a lot of time
and energy from this particular
Committee in the afternoon starting at
1:00 we'll be
executing uh eight bills so they will be
10:15
1458 and
1646 those are bills which are not on
the list for today second and third
pardon me second and third 10 it started
out with 10:15 then
1087 then
1287 now that executive session if we
don't get through all those in that
afternoon will continue to March
13th and on March 13th those which we
carry forward we will address but we
will also address those six bills which
were listed as Co-op bills or merging
bills of the sa saus and everything
associated with the organization and
structure of Education in this state
from a management
perspective so that be on 313 that's
Wednesday I don't know yet whether we're
going to have sessions on Thursday
that's still an undecided session on
Thursday on the 13th will start at 10
o'cl and I would suspect that the
caucuses we will have will be prior to
that so we won't have to take from the
time of the
schedule yes thank you just want sure
heard this correctly you started on the
11th and then you went to the 13th so
you're not going to do the 12th is that
correct the 12th is voting day and this
place is this place is closed down okay
that's perfect thank you yeah you're
welcome and then uh what we have so that
takes care of on the 13th another six
bills so you add the 68 there's 14 bills
that leaves 20 to do and so on March
18th we have all the bills including
anything which we don't have taken care
of today on the 13th there's 20 bills
there that are
listed um you can they their bills which
are on the calendar for today and and uh
bills May overflow so I'm not going to
go through and list those we'll be
starting that off at 10 o'clock and if
we don't get done that day we will
continue that exec session to the
19th and the 19th being Tuesday we will
have to wrap this up by the 20th at noon
we have to have all the reports the
oldfashioned blurbs whether you're for
or against to the clerk's office by noon
on the
20th and or at least upstairs to the
attorneys which review them here and
then it comes back to myself then it
goes over the clerk's office so that's
our schedule um where we are as far as
upcoming work so you can plan on working
on on those particular
days
and we're going to take the tough bills
up first on those days in the morning
when we have more energy to deal with
them we'll take up those easy bills
which we have concurrence on in the
afternoon and that's what we're going to
do today as well uh we just had a
meeting where we able we know the bills
which we concur on we know the bills
which we don't and so we're going to go
ahead and start with the tough bills um
any questions from the committee on that
all right so let's take the first bill
up um what we got here um we have there
people here see speak on orgen see okay
so we yeah we have up
here we know we're going with that we
this we know
where're well let's just sort of work
right down this list with those bills um
we're going to hold on 10 1087 and not
deal with that this this
morning or
today
well 1084 yeah you you just dump uh we
also had a hold on 1084 we're waiting
for amending language he's got the
amendment on that yeah okay
1087 we had a hold on that that was
originally scheduled for yesterday
afternoon commission study to
information on media literacy so we're
going to start off with the next one
down the that's an that's one we agree
on right yeah yeah oh yeah I think so
yeah yep you think so yeah yeah what we
write down
here start
this well we let's start like with
1418 use of EA efas to purchase school
uniforms
yeah yeah representative pel I look to
you for a
motion
148 you got it I move itl on House Bill
1418 so we have motion for itl on 148
this abill use of efas to purchase
School UNS made by representative Pell
and second by representative
Miler further discussion from making the
motion yes thank you um this bill is
um I'm I'm moving itl because school
uniforms can be an integral part of an
education and requirement for students
to attend private schools therefore
they're a necessary part of their
education and I would consider that I
would consider removing this from the
education Freedom accounts to um be
inappropriate from the second is there
any
discussion any further discussion from
the committee not seeing
any Madam clerk would you call the role
on
148 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
baloni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon no and chairman lad
yes 19 Y is one day any objections to
consent thank
you moving on
down
um was an easy one 1458 from yesterday
yeah let's take 1458 authorizing parents
to remove children from the English
language learner
program I recognize represent cordelli
for a motion uh thank you I'd like to
move uh in room
study I'll second that so we have a
motion made on
1458 this is authorizing parents to
remove children from elll program the
motion is interim study the Motions made
by represent cordelli and second by
represent luno further discussion from
the maker of the motion uh just that um
I think there were issues raised on both
sides um of the the bill uh during the
hearing and I have since talked to the
uh Prime sponsor who is okay with inter
own study and she would like to do more
work on
it represent
luno I think that sums it up Y is there
any further discussion from the
committee not seeing any Madam clerk
when you're
ready motion is in room study Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus representative beler yes
representative dry yes representa
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative WKA no representative
Hall yes representative albone yes this
one right here representative cascaden
yes representative Damon yes chairman
lad yes 19 y one
day thank you very much uh any
objections to consent no it was 19 to1
19 19 to1
yes okay that's on consent next bill
we're going to deal with is
1205 12 five this
conf
okay and I'd like to recognize
representa cordelli for a motion thank
you I'd like to move on to pass is there
a
second represent Bel seconds the motion
there's a mo a motion a to pass on uh
1205 this is a bill relative to women's
School
sports uh made by representa cordelli
and second by representative beler
represent cordelli you're recognized for
a any discussion thank you um yes I
would like to U Move a to to pass on an
amendment that I will be passing around
um which is amendment
H is there a second I'll second
it okay we have a a motion on
the in front of us here it's a relative
to an amendment which you all have in a
second here as it comes around that
Amendment is0
9738 dealing with um women's
sports and the motion is uh OTP on the
amendment represent cordelli
were as the maker of that we're ready
when you're ready
okay thank you very much um yeah this
bill um has had a lot of work put into
it by um citizens as well as the prime
sponsor um representative Andress um the
amendment um makes uh a number of
changes um and that I think one of the
major ones is that um it uh eliminates
from uh the bill uh at col
Athletics uh it limits it to U middle
and high school
students um and also eliminates uh
grades K through
four um so I think that's one of the
main uh differences in the bill there
are some just changes in in
definitions uh but the uh Amendment uh
goes on to talk about um uh provisions
of birth certific ific Ates um and um
issues related to that um as well as uh
on the uh second page um specifies uh
possible causes of action um for
students um who are uh impacted um by
uh
nonadherence um
basically uh to the uh bill um and try
to
clarify uh some things from the original
bill
um in addition to uh as I mentioned the
birth certificate and um issues related
to the uh birth certificate which I
think are important in terms of uh
defining the uh biological sex of the
participant um I think that
um I I'll leave it there I think some
other people are probably going to
comment on
this okay I I made the second on that
and
uh I may just I I'll address a little
bit of it right now um while I was a
school administrator I had the
responsibility for coordinating
Athletics in the keenai peninsula
burough School District that's a school
district a size of West Virginia that's
in
Alaska and we had a a huge population up
there
and we um I had members of my own family
who were running in track and
field and my daughter was a runner and
went on full right scholarship to Texas
A&M ran for them my other daughter came
down as a point guard of a college here
in the east coast um subsequently I have
a granddaughter who participated and
Captain the University of main indoor
and outdoor track teams
and set pentathlon records for New
England against all the
colleges uh I have a grandson that's
very much involved in playing right now
in in the basketball league over New
York State dealing with the Liberty
league and doing quite well um and I
believe that Sports uh that we have and
have known have been Guided by Title
9 and that's providing the equity and
equality that we needed to elevate women
in sports like remember when my wife was
a young student before I knew her and
played basketball over in Rumford Maine
um girls were only allowed to take three
dribbles and had to pass the ball off
things have changed in athletics today
if you watched how the Carolina girls
are playing
basketball uh in South Carolina it's
amazing what we've seen as a a total
growth in terms of uh elevating the
level of of women's sports
however I'm concerned that when we're
putting a person that's changed their
gender and I'm not going to go with all
the the issues associated with that but
a male is stronger there's no question
about
it and I saw that occur when I had the
granddaughter who was running for main
Orno running against uh an individual
from Franklin Pierce who was a that
national champion for for divis
two and that individual one easily hands
over all the girls which were
running and and it's so there there is
an issue out there I would hate to see
my my grandson who's another athlete
only in a different way who is a center
for a Collegiate team he's 7 foot tall
and could he be changing and participate
in that sport as a girl what would he do
he devastate what's going on in the
court so I think there are a lot of
rationalities I've seen in my own family
and as administrator where I had to deal
with issues like this in Alaska this
bill right here is one where we're not
touching the Collegiate at all but what
we are doing is we're addressing the
high school and the middle schools and
recognizing the intermal schools it
doesn't matter anybody should be able to
play on those intermal times and have
fun and enjoy but when you're getting to
the areas the middle and the high school
then it starts to break apart and we've
seen what's happened in Connecticut
we've seen what's happened where people
losing their scholarship opportunities
due to the fact that they've been beat
out by a person that changed their
gender while they were in high
school so I for one have a very
difficult time uh seeing what's going on
with this whole opportunity for young
ladies in our Athletics today and I'm
trying to get it back to where we've had
it and where it provides opportunity
which is fair and Equitable for all the
young women in this state thank
you any other discussion from the
committee represent pel thank you Mr
chair yes this this bill is actually
very personal to me over 10 years ago my
daughter came to me when there was a
transgender Athlete on her team and said
Mom this isn't fair what can we do about
it and my response to her was would you
like to make a federal case out of this
because I knew that was exactly where we
were going and now we're 10 years into
this and we are starting to see what
happens to women when they are displaced
by men on sports teams we have seen
injuries occur we have been telling our
women and girls to sit back and let men
take their place um I we all received in
the mail a letter from somebody who is a
well-respected High School cross country
coach I have Co coached with this man
and he's concerned about women losing
scholarships and it's more than that
we've heard a representative say that um
oh maybe a man competing a boy competing
in the women's high jump isn't really a
big deal because it's a sport that
people don't watch anyway well the girls
that are competing in that high jump
that's the world to
them the person who sent this letter to
me said well maybe women shouldn't it it
it only matters if they're losing
scholarships no it matters if you are
displaced on any team for any reason by
somebody who is not competing fairly
with
you I really understand the issues that
are facing people who are have
conflicting
um gender identity it it's I can't even
imagine what they're facing but
if we don't pass a bill like this we are
letting our women and our daughters down
and we might as well go back to 1919
before we had the right to vote
representative
Tanner thank you
um and I would say as I have many times
before that um I am a person who has
taught physical education who's who's
competed in
sports uh who's coached women in sports
um who was a person who benefited
greatly during title n uh title n just
like uh our Chairman's wife uh probably
we about the same age uh went from a
time when we didn't have opportunity um
you know on Little League baseball or um
to actually play basketball the way it
was meant to be
played um so I am a strong person for
women's in sports but I'm also a strong
person for
non-discrimination and this is really
about discrimination it's about
discriminating against less than
1% of the kids that go to school less
than 1% so we're talking about not
taking over a sport or taking over a
group we're talking about people who
um
are trying to fit in who are trying to
be be um their authentic self and it
must be very difficult and they they
have to go through um bullying and a lot
of other things let alone adults telling
them uh that they can't be part of a
team um I wanted to address a couple of
things before I get to the part that's
really um sent me right over the roof um
the first part is scholar ships when you
go for a scholarship for a college it
isn't based on one performance it isn't
based on your records or whatever as
much as it is on your work ethic and
your native athletic ability and what
the coaches at that college think that
you're going to be able to provide so
nobody nobody has been denied a
scholarship because a transgender
student beat them
out
injuries happen all the time in sports
they're part of being in sports you take
that risk in fact that's one of the kind
of fun things about it is you test your
body to the limits um you're trying to
be as competitive as possible and when
you do that sometimes injuries happen
there has been no injuries directly
related to a trans person actually um
causing that injury outside of what it
would normally be in an athletic event
okay then we go on to um this high jump
thing that's been circulated through and
it's actually my school the school that
I worked and coached at kir Sarge and I
have to tell you how upset I am about
this that this poor person has been um
put in in emails put in letters that
have been sent even a a whole pamphlet
that was sent up and it was all full of
misinformation uh misinformation in the
fact that yes this person did win the
high jump at 5'2 there was also a girl
from summersworth who jumped and
completed the 52 um height as well but
came in second place because she had a
Miss at 5
foot the record for women's high jump in
the state of New Hampshire is 6
feet okay not 52 which uh was intimated
in in that letter um the winner of the
boys high jump in that same meat was 6
feet and in competition you should know
that in high jump the bars raised 2 Ines
at a time not one inch so that was
another thing in the in the little
pamphlet that went around to out this
person uh that was just totally totally
wrong so I guess the last thing that I I
wanted to go to about this amendment
that I think is just outrageous and
totally discriminatory and is going to
end up in a court of law and that's
school athletes cause of action and if
you I know you just got this amendment
so you probably didn't have time to see
this but not only do we have and we've
had people in this uh come see us who
have had puberty blockers who are um
transitioning and they've had puberty
blockers before
puberty and what this bill is doing is
it's it's making it so that I would
assume a parent could walk up to the
coach and say hey I think that girl is a
trans girl because we know as we see
them here they look just like girls
because they've transitioned through
hormone
replacement and then they have to go
through all this this rigot to try and
prove that they're they're female and um
then it not only that but it says that
the person the people that bring it can
actually have civil action initiated
when two years of the harm occur
harm harm is a result of what and
damages what damages okay are we talking
about somebody that feels uncomfortable
about a trans person being being around
them okay and then um they can get
sued it's just this first of all it's
just cruel to pick on
kids who are going through a gender
crisis who have done the
hormones and and then put them through
this and their parents through this
we've we've had them come and tell you
some of the problems that they've been
having you know we yesterday we talked
about the mask history well you know you
think it's tough transgender kids have
it even tougher and transgender parents
have it tougher the people that have
those kids and and to single them out
just so it's a good campaign thing and
just because we you know you're afraid
of people because they're different um I
think is no reason to make these kids um
Paras
Paras one of the reasons you're not
using elementary students and you're not
using College people is because NCI
NCAA is the governing body for
Collegiate
Sports nhia the New Hampshire inter
Scholastic Athletic Association is the
association that's set in the state and
it's it's a National Association of
States uh inter Scholastic athletic
teams they are the people who look at
how competition is happening make the
determination just like the Olympic
teams do about who can compete
fairly and also they adjust the rules
for competition to make it as safe as
possible they also oversee the
officiating of different
sports so what we're doing is we're
doing what the inter Scholastic Athletic
Association
we're we're taking over their job okay
and they are people who are sports
athletic athletic people um that have
been trained in that there're also
people who are athletic trainers they're
also Sports Physicians they're also
people from college that that are um
endocrinologists and and involved in
this that's that's how they make their
decision we are a group of 20 people and
out of 20 people we don't know the same
information and have the same
professional experience as these people
that are on these regulatory boards and
the regulatory board center around
hormones and um I'm obviously going to
vote against this bill I guess that's
probably uh you know stating the obvious
but I just want to say that that I'm
ashamed to be a part of this bill to
even talk about this bill to even see
this amendment because how cruel it is
how discriminatory it is and how
ignorant it is thank you representa
cordelli uh thank you I have to I guess
take offense to the um statement that uh
this is a good campaign thing and that's
why it's being brought forward um I
think Title 9 if I'm not mistaken it
dates back to 1972 or at least the early
1970s um women
um fought for a long time to get
equality in sports um you
know I you know I'm not going to be back
around that time but I know that um
there were uh very many issues and years
of uh discussion about the fact of the
um and even recently in terms of um
professional soccer or um the US soccer
team uh that um male athletes were
getting paid way more um than um female
athletes uh more Scholarships in college
um Etc so getting a quality for women in
sports was not a campaign thing back
then and it's not a campaign thing now
as I think representative Pell was
getting at this is
um might want to call it a women's
rights issue
um and four or five years ago maybe you
remember um chairman lad we had uh
another bill um like this um in our
committee and uh that was about the time
that um uh there was a high school
athletic uh track competition in
Connecticut and three transgender males
took the first three spots in and the
state
championships and knocked out the
leading uh female uh runners in the
state up to that point um and they were
um denied scholarships they did not get
scholarships they would have if they had
been um uh competing against just fellow
uh female athletes so it certainly has
impacted and there certainly has been
injuries um not long ago there was a um
I think it was field hockey um uh young
lady had her teeth knocked out when uh
transgender um uh male from the other
team uh through the uh soccer soccer
ball at her and knocked her teeth out
there's no soccer ball in field hockey
well I'm sorry I misspoke right I I I I
think I realized that I think I
misspoke excuse me I think I have the
floor if you want to rebut it rebut it
later after the person has Flo it's not
you keep your comments until you have
the floor
please um so yes I misspoke and this was
a soccer uh game
um so there have been injuries we've
seen it in um high school wrestling um
Collegiate wrestling um with
transgenders wrestling against um
females so um to say there have been no
denial of scholarships no injuries I
think is a a gross exaggeration and um I
really uh as the maker the maker of this
amendment um I find it offensive to say
that this is I'm doing this as a
campaign
thing further further testimony
represent Terry thank
you uh in addition to my having diff
difficulty
accepting this uh modern uh
notion uh and dystopian notion if I
might say that there is really uh no
difference between uh biological males
and biological females particularly when
it comes to the matter of contact uh
competitive Sports at the middle school
and the high school level I I also
believe um that facts matter and we've
had the assertion made
in this debate this discussion on this
bill that there have been no injuries
sustained as a result of a transnational
a transgendered person competing in
women's sports that is factually
incorrect In the far away place of
Massachusetts a high school basket girls
basketball team was forced to Forfeit
its game after a transgender player on
the opposing team injured three players
players the game was between the
Collegiate Charter School of L's girl L
girls against Kip
Massachusetts
three female players were injured by a
transgendered male biological male on
the other team and this forced on the
grounds of safety and this is really
what we're talking about here safety for
women safety for women on the grounds of
safety for women the coach forfeited the
game to the other
team so it is factually incorrect to
assert that there have been no injuries
sustained as a result of transgendered
players being allowed to play
competitively in intramural sports in
this country and that is only one of
many instances where this has occurred
so to make the statement that there have
been no injuries is factually and
egregiously Incorrect and it is
offensive thank you representer
Damon thank you Mr chair excuse
me I would like to read these remarks
from a New Hampshire
resident I'm writing to you hoping that
I can count on you to put up a strong
fight against
hp25 I'm not actually a resident of the
area you represent I live in Newport
voicing my opinion to my actual state
senator or Representatives would be a
total waste of time I am the proud but
increasingly fearful father of a
transgender girl hb25 would take away
her opportunity to play school sports my
daughter like most transgender athletes
doesn't stand out during games she is
average at best but loves the team
aspect of the one sport she plays she
wants to be able to do what her friends
do she wants to enjoy being part of a
team she has been accepted by the
majority of her team and it's
heartwarming to see parents from our
town that we know have voiced anti-trans
sentiments cheer her on and yell her
name while the far right will try to
make everyone believe that trans women
are dominating Sports it's just not the
case girls school sports in New
Hampshire are not being dominated or
ruined by trans girls and they are
playing I think trans girls should be
allowed to play at worst I could live
with each School District deciding for
themselves if your Republican colleagues
actually believed in limited government
they would leave it to the districts
instead of passing a discriminatory
state law there is no truer expression
of freedom than continuing to be
yourself in spite of all the people who
continue to say you shouldn't exist and
you have no rights vote down 1205 thank
you and that's my
stance thank you uh represent
Woodcock thank you chairman L um I is it
okay to ask question about the amendment
sure yeah we're in discussion right now
okay thank you um first off I just to my
colleague to the left I know he wants to
be factually correct it wasn't interal
Sports and intercol AIC the difference
between High School interal you said
inter murals only faculty collect that's
you said um either case my question uh
regards section two I'm looking at line
um uh 12 if I
may I just want to understand this uh
and either you Mr chair or the sponsor
of the amendment
do I interpret line 12 the private
school piece uh sir to mean if if I am a
acad private Academy playing against uh
kenet high school that if I have a trans
male or a trans female on my team then
my can high school is not allowed to
participate is that what that means
[Music]
um so that's how I interpret
it
I I believe that um the intent here is
that um again we want to make it a uh a
fair playing field um for uh female
students in public schools so this is a
protection against um the instance when
a private school would be competing um
against that public school and there is
a a transgender athlete uh in uh the uh
private school who is a competitor in
that uh uh in that game May I follow
thank you well just respond thank you I
I understand the intent of what you just
said R cordelli but but that doesn't
negate what this says it says if I'm in
a private if a private school brings a
transgender male or transgender female
to Kenneth High School to play in a say
Spring sport uh does this mean Kenneth
High School can't play
them it says that the um it must be
expressly designated that one of these I
understand that asking I'm asking what
that means I understand that I
understand I think I think well would be
in the um purview of kennet High School
uh to decline to play in that game we've
seen that around the country and other
uh uh other um schools in other states
I'm not saying they can't decline that
means they can't
play I I don't see where it says they
cannot play okay may I follow Mr chair
yes thank you on the am uh I understand
Item
B uh
should there be an item C the females
can't play on a male
sport um yeah possibly it's not right it
doesn't it doesn't say that right but um
I think I'm not sure I'm not sure if
we've seen U many of those um instances
I don't think that there have been any
in New Hampshire that I'm aware of well
I'm not Mr M yeah thank you um
so I I say that in terms I'm thinking
particularly of the sport of of softball
and baseball baseball particularly and
football where we've seen
females uh this year uh playing p and
kick and quarterback uh on an all boy
typically all young men uh uh boys
football team so this this I just
understand it seems to me it's it is
discriminat to that extent that it's
discriminatory so that was that was my
only two questions cuz as I read 12 it
means private schools that come we can't
play against them if we can it uh and
see is missing that it's not fair for
once it's fair for women but not fair
for men it sort of seems discriminatory
to me because there's no C there are
there are there further questions
representative
beler thank you Mr chair not a question
but just a yeah discuss anecdote you
might say about this um you might not be
able to tell about looking at me but
there was a time that I was very
athletic
and very competitive 9 a little after
that
2000s I was so athletic and so
competitive that in high school I was
removed from gym class no longer allowed
to participate in gym class because I
was judged to be an object of danger to
the young women in that class now it
took me off a little bit of time but let
me tell you that in hindsight I am so
glad they did that because let me tell
you at 14 15 16 years old I was not
properly in control of myself nor did I
have the presence of mind to tone myself
down when I was in those situations and
I would have had that on my conscience
if I had badly hurt someone thank you
thank you represent
leus first I want to start with saying I
am not afraid of people who are
different from me and I don't like the
implication I have friends who are trans
I grew up before uh Title 9 there were
Sports I wanted to play that I couldn't
play because I was a girl those Sports
now exist I've seen a lot of change in
the attitudes towards women women are no
longer or weren't any longer told to sit
down shut up don't complain and let the
boys beat you but now I see this as
discriminatory against women athletes
because they are being told no you can't
complain no you can't say anything
you'll get in trouble because you be
considered transphobic and all that
other stuff um sit down shut up don't
complain let them take your position let
them get the scholarships so now we're
back to pre-title 9 we're back to you're
just a woman you don't
count and it's the same thing I grew up
with and I don't think it's right but if
I thought I could get away with a bill
that said all schools must have um mixed
Sports co-ed Sports I would do that
except that we're told we're not allow
we're not supposed to be doing that but
um because that that should be a local
control issue but I think the answer to
this is to have lots of co-ed Sports and
that way everybody can play sports and
it isn't an issue so we can have boy
Sports girl Sports and coed Sports and
that's what I would encourage people to
do if they want to solve the issue and I
think it is an issue I think trans kids
absolutely should be able to play sports
I say have coed teams thank
you somebody hasn't spoken for a little
bit here representative
Miler thank you Mr
chair
um I hesitate to really respond to this
because it's it's a controversial issue
there's no question about this now my
concern is the volume of trans students
who want to participate in
sports they want to participate in
sports not because of a
scholarship they want to participate to
be member of a
team to learn what leadership skills
are organization
skills you know sometimes I think that
people think that trans girls are men in
drag right they're not that at
all for a student to make the
decision to become a trans
individual it's not done willy-nilly
it's a it's a major life decision that
one
makes and we've heard families come
before us here and talk about the
decision ision that the family had to
make to
recognize the gender
identification that an individual wants
to
make and when that decision is made it
puts into place a whole series of
activities that an individual goes
through it's not just I'm going to wear
a dress
now you're going through a whole
hormonal kind of a situation it's under
medical
guidance it's a significant change here
now I can understand the issue of I
didn't get a
scholarship but let's jge the position I
scholarship to the number of students
who participate in a sport that are just
average and they just want to be
there this bill would deny him that
opportunity
frankly one of the persons I love to
watch is Kon
Clark she's better than any male athlete
in college right
now all
right and my concern is is
that the Caitlyn Clarks of the world are
going to be
okay but I'm concerned about those who
aren't at that level of proficiency in
athletics they just want to be there
they just want
to be able to participate in something
that they want to
do after they've made that decision that
they want to be their true
self this bill denies them and that's
what I'm concerned about the issue of
the right of action I mean this it it
the the penalties that are in this
amendment are egregious and I think are
really an insult to every child who
decides that they want to change their
gender identity and participate in
sports this anti-trans bill that's what
this is let's put it right out
there and that's why I'm not going to
support
this and I'm not going to support the
major bill because I'm concerned about
those children those kids who are out
there who are not going to be
be the one who's going to receive the
scholarship but the greater percentage
of those who just want to
participate and be them be there with
their
friends thank
you representa
pel thank
you so many things have come up and I
hate to say that I do have experience
with this
situation um to be begin with there was
conversation about these um about
transgender people both sides men and
women being under the care of
Physicians and in particular
endocrinologists and I would like to
point out that endocrinologists stand to
make a significant amount of money once
you get a child on transgender hormones
you have a patient for life it is a
million billion dollar industry
um as far as the nhiaa being um the
governing body more than 10 years ago
lgbtq
organizations took the approach of
getting of changing the policy on every
single
athletic um organization at the state
level and allowing transgender athletes
to perform in sports opposite of their
sex they took the back door approach and
that's why we need this legislation now
and when it comes to lawsuits if you I
want you to recall that I told my
daughter that this would be a federal
case if we wanted to pursue it so I feel
like it would have been cruel and
unusual punishment for my family to have
pursued a
lawsuit um and we talk a lot we're
talking about people getting hurt but
what we physically we've talk spoken
about people getting hurt what we
haven't spoken about is the damage to
our daughters
self-esteem these our daughters are also
trying to be their authentic
selves when they are told that they
can't compete on a team because there
are tryouts so someone who's physically
stronger than you is going to take your
spot it you may be the second to last
choice on the
team and you may not make the team
because just because of train
a um a boy who is transitioning to be a
female is one step ahead of you you
might lose your spot this isn't about
scholarships this is about women's
self-esteem this is a pro women pro
daughter Pro girl bill and I will
support
it uh represent
Tanner so yes we've had a lot of
uh discussion around here and there's an
awful lot of misinformation thrown out
about transgender and about
transitioning and I think it's
um I think it's a real insult to
Physicians of all types including
endocrinologists to to say that they
would do something that um would be just
for the
money uh to keep to transition a kid and
keep under under that puberty blocker
forever for just for money I think
that's against uh hypocritic oath and a
few other things the thing about what
we've heard and as I pointed out this
whole thing about this high school high
jumper um and obviously there was no
safety uh problem with that um is that
there was misinformation purposely sent
out misinformation which has just been
unb un believable in our emails
unbelievable to people so it's hard to
believe when somebody says oh there was
you know three people hurt on a
basketball team
well as I said before there has not been
any sports
injuries attributed to a transgender
athlete who's done it on purpose and and
people get their teeth knocked out in
field hockey unfortunately and they now
gone to mouth uh guards on that uh women
girls got their teeth knocked out in
Lacrosse that's happened now that's
that's got a safety issue if if a
basketball team uh has an issue with
injuries and something that's being
unfairly done on the court that's an
officials uh problem and the nhiaa is
part of a federal part of a national not
federal but National independent
Athletic Association that are overseen
by principes and superintendents and
coaches and athletic directors and um
they make the decisions as to whether
this the sports are how the sports are
run how the tournaments are run Etc so I
think that's a little bit of an issue
too but I think you also have to look at
this bill and say why is it okay for
kids up to you know fifth grade to be
able to compete together why is that
okay and then after after fifth grade
all of a sudden it's a real big problem
until you get to college and gee we're
not going to do anything about college
and the reason is that it's all about
hormones and it's about hormones that if
they go on puberty blockers before they
go through puberty um it's we've seen
these kids here um there there should
should be no no super super advantage
and just like representative Miler
pointed out and people people our age a
lot of times what we're thinking of is
Boys in drag or men in Drag and it's not
guys are not going to put on skirts just
to play on girl Sports so um this is a
bill that is
anti-discrimination anti-trans that's
the only purpose of this bill and um
it's cruel and and that's not something
we should do here thank you okay I'm
gonna just comment here one more time
I wish many of you could have a family
where you grow up and watch your your
daughters compete and how hard they work
and how hard they have tried to excel in
in sport be it in high school I saw that
with the one that went on A&M on a full
right scholarship for track and field
and that's a tough thing to do at a a a
school of 44,000 kids
and you you talk about
discrimination I think that without this
bill the athlete is being discriminated
against who has tried and tried and
tried and worked so hard over all those
years in Middle School grade school
middle school high school to to come to
the to the top of the Heap but all of a
sudden
encounter a person of another birth
gender that's strong stronger than you
are you watch the tournament that I just
watched two weeks ago over in Geneva New
York Liberty League I watched them play
ball
boys my grandson who's been scoring
about 18 19 points a
game sustained in that game a broken
nose he also had an ankle injury about
three weeks prior to that it's a contact
sport you put a person of that caliber
in amongst girls you are going to have
injury we're already having it within
the boy
Sports
and I'm not saying that that inju should
be I I think the ref's got to get on top
of it however um when we when we're
looking at I'm looking at the
psychological impact to the girls that
worked all their lives to get where they
are and then lose the opportunity to
reach that goal that theyve strive to do
and they got they got it's okay if they
it's wonderful if they get beat by
another girl that's on that team that's
what it's all about there be but there
you know if I were to go back and and
and quote some of the the sayings from
Vince Lombardi and probably many of you
don't know remember Vince Lombardi but a
wonderful coach over in in in Green Bay
there's only one place and that's first
place and that's how these girls think
and when they're working towards this
we're I'm looking at the High Caliber
girl and yes you're looking of others
that have chosen the opposite
gender or are are turn you know gone
that way as a
transgender and yes there there's
psychological impacts there too but
there's also discrimination on the other
side too and that's what I'm concerned
that for we're we're we're forgetting
about that youngster the ones that I had
grw up in my family and I watched and I
watched how hard they worked and they
earned what they earned they earned a
free ride to college as a result of that
ability to be successful on the track or
in
basketball so I I I think that when we
throw things around that we're talking
about discrimination here no we're not
talking about that we're watching the
destruction of Title
Nine we're watching that going down the
toilet and it is in this
country so I think there's
misinformation out there and I think
it's time we return sport the way it's
supposed to be run thank you represent
cordelli and then represent Damon thank
you um I just wanted to go back to line
17 and 18 which say athletic teams or
Sports designated for females women or
girls shall not be open to students of
the male sex we're talking about male
sex and there's two
Sexes so this is the male sex um shall
not participate on a female or girls
team um representative Woodcock raised
the issue of um and maybe
female
um athletes participating on a Mal's
team that's their
choice they're making a conscious
decision knowing that they're playing
with uh possibly um male athletes who
are bigger and stronger and maybe
risking injury they're making that
conscious decision and their parents are
making that conscious decision um
females coming up against a team with a
male
athlete male sex a
transgender um don't are not making that
conscious
decision they're playing against that
team because it's on their
schedule they would have to as we talked
about they could make the team make the
conscious decision and there have been
instances where they have chosen not to
play that in that uh game because of the
situation with the uh transgender
Athlete on the other team so in lines 17
and 18 it's about the male sex and it's
about physical injury and the conscious
decision uh
thereof rson Damon talking about
thank you Mr chair I have two things one
there is a state Regional and National
shortage of endocrinologists they are
not lacking for patients the weit time
to get an appointment with an
endocrinologist is very lengthy the idea
that
those very significantly trained medical
professionals would provide this care to
a person to make money and have a
lifetime patient is absurd I'm offended
for my colleagues in endocrinology that
we would even make a statement like that
here
separately if we are talking about
safety in sports we should be talking
about safety in men's sports women's
sports girls Sports boy Sports anybody's
Sports there are lots of injuries in
sports I think maybe we need to take a
careful look at that whether as part of
an inter from study for this bill or
separately because it is not by any
means that this is different this is
just another situation in which some
students will get hurt students are
getting hurt anyway and we need to
address
that okay so what we're going to do and
I'm not going to go with any more
testimony right here let's just call
this vote on on the amendment which we
have before us we have an amendment in
front of us
0973 uh this is for HB
1205 and the uh motion on on the table
on front of us is to for OTP on that
Amendment uh Madam clerk would you
please call the role Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Heath no Representative wock no
representative Hall no representative B
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 days so the motion in front of
us now is with that uh motion uh failing
we will move on with the OTP for HB 1205
further discussion on the primary motion
represent
cordelli um I think we've heard a lot of
discussion so I think we can just vote
on the OTP any further discussion on the
motion of OTP for HB
1205 not seeing the Madam clerk would
you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cor yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no and chairman
lead yes 10 y 10 y okay that that motion
fails representative Miler or represent
Tanner who's going to make the motion
represent Tanner Lun who's making it
down there I'd like to make a motion to
it the L this bill is there a second
second okay we have motion made by
represent Tanner itl and second by
represent Miler represent Tanner do you
want to speak to your motion I think
I've said enough represent Miler any
further discussion from the committee
not seeing any uh mam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no Representative
eler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Coro no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman no 10
y 10 days okay so we're where we usually
end up with no recommendation uh so
it'll go in the calendar as such with an
otpa from one side and itl on the other
side and represent
Tanner pardon me well it be the
amendment will go along with it yeah the
amendment goes into the
calendar so and you're doing the
y okay thank
you
okay what time is
it oh we can do some of the checked off
ones okay what we're going to do is
because we we are going to be coming up
here in lunch in about 25 minutes so
we're going to jump down and
uh address HB
1691 that's a definition of an adequate
public
education and I'll hand the gavel over
to represent cord cordelli uh thank you
very much Mr chairman
um House Bill 16
91 I have it some Place yeah I'm trying
to get it
too yeah okay is relative to the
definition of an
adequate are we doing 91 yes yeah
relative to the definition of an
adequate public education and I call on
um representative lad for a motion yes
thank you very much I'd like to Mo make
the motion of interum study
second uh discussion representative lad
no no
represent Miler I'm good thank you
anyone from the committee have
a comment or discussion on
1691 seen none Madam
clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes represent ative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock
representative Hall yes representative B
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman L yes
20 A's zero a any objections while this
is consent unanimous okay uh next one
we're going to do is
hp605 this is alternative ation programs
for granting
credit
1605 recognize represent
McDonald thank you Mr chair I move
itl second okay we have a motion made by
repon McDonald is itl and second by
represent luno uh represent McDonald
care to speak to your motion I would
thank you during the public hearing the
sponsor stated that the bill was at
least in part inspired by the recent
approval of a financial literacy course
made by Prager u in other words this
bill flips the concept of federalism on
its head as the legislature we would be
counteracting the decision made by the
State Board of Education which is an
executive body moreover this bill aims
to do so without just cause no evidence
was presented against any program
including the course available via
prageru I'll also take this opportunity
to add to the record that proper notice
was not given to prageru so that
Representatives could defend the serious
Federal accusations made against them
and we should not set a precedent of
supporting legislation under these
circumstances in addition the sponsor
admitted to not having completed the
videos she objected to in fact no one
who testified had completed watching the
videos at best this indicates the
legislation is unprepared which is the
definition of inexpedient to legislate
but returning to the content of the bill
it would be overly generous to say that
this is a solution in search of a
problem instead the bill creates
problems for example we do not know the
potential impacts we do not know how
many service providers would no longer
be options and most importantly we not
know how this would adversely impact
educational attainment under no
circumstances can we support this bill
in any form thank you prent luno yes
thank you Mr chair unfortunately while I
did second the uh the itl recommendation
I disagree with everything that
representative McDonald just just stated
and none of what she said represents um
um uh the Democratic position on on um
on this bill so with all due respect to
the representative and um I would like
to request the chair that uh that
representative McDonald and I co-write
the um the committee report on
this okay would you like to explain any
of the your objections to what
representative McDonald was saying or so
so one of them is that um is that we
have another bill uh in play that that I
believe better covers the um uh this uh
this position with regards to um making
sure that uh that programs approved
under the what's known as the learn
everywhere program comply with state
federal and their own um um
anti-discrimination laws that
anti-discrimination policies are good
for people all across the United States
and and and uh and that um uh that while
Public Schools uh certainly and and I
think we'd all agree uh have to comply
with um and should comply with
anti-discrimination uh laws that
programs that um that are ancillary to
Public Schools such as programs approved
under the learn
everywhere um approved by the state
should also be compliant with that and
um and for those reasons I think um I
think we have another bill that uh that
better addresses this better positions
the State Board of Education to uh to
provide oversight into compliance with
those uh anti-discrimination policies
and um and for those reasons I don't
think um 16005 is necessary at this time
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair as
a representative made a request to
co-write the committee report I'd humbly
request that that does not occur and I
have a question for clarification is it
possible for two reports be committed if
it's the same motion no no it's the same
motion you got to work together on it um
there were some issues which we had
discussed regarding the finances of this
the the costs associated with it um and
um do only schools of those receiving
public funds discriminate there are some
several issues which we I think in our
discussion ear like that we needed an
amendment for clarification on where
we're going with various portions of
this bill and that it wasn't ready uh so
maybe what we need to do is put this
forward for inum stud but try to work on
some
recommendation uh that we can put into
the the committee report which comes to
that Common Ground I think both sides
are saying we need to do some things
with it but uh exactly what is what you
we we need to come to some compromise on
so so Mr chair I think the motion was
itl right oh I thought it was inter
study but okay I'm just I back off then
okay I mean I certainly support interim
study but think you know supporting itl
and and U you know I I I I I I certainly
think representative McDonald and I can
civil work together to put together a um
uh a committee report that that reflects
both both the the some of the the
positions that um that she's articulated
as well as the the positions that I
think more reflect um we have done that
before we have done that before in bill
so okay I appreciate I would encourage
both of the Reps to get together bang
their heads and come up with an NL
recommendation that's satisfactory to
both sides and we don't really have to
bang our heads
yes be careful so okay so any further
discussion on this Phil it's getting
close to lunchtime I didn't have any
breakfast this morning so as I is itl
I okay so further discussion Madam clerk
would you please call the RO the
recommendation as itl on the bill VI
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner no
representative luno yes
representative Heath yes representative
W yes representative Hall yes any other
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon
yes chairman
L yes 19 y One n okay
vote1 good with consent thank
you let's try to get a couple more done
if we can can uh before lunch uh 1646
relative to Charter Public
Schools
1646 I'd like to move you want me to
Mo interim study yeah go ahead yeah I'll
I'll I'll um move inter room study on
1646 and represent Bel you want to
second that sure yes okay thank you very
much so we have a recommendation on
study on on this bill 1646 relative to
Charter Public Schools uh represent luno
do you want to speak to your motion sure
thanks very much so I think I think the
bill was really intended to to go at to
some structural deficiencies with the um
with how uh Charter Public Schools are
are are defined and organized in uh in
statute and I think since filing the
bill we've received some uh information
from the the uh uh jointly from the
Department of Education as well as the
Department of Justice that U that agrees
that there are structural deficiencies
to how Charters are are are defined and
organized in statute and that uh they
would like to um to contribute
additional work on this so uh inter
study is really the the right place to
put this for now and um and then we can
come forward uh hopefully with a
bipartisan um uh Solution that's
comprehensive uh in in incorporating the
um uh the findings that the doj and the
doe have thank you representative beler
thank you Mr chair and I I I tend to
agree with a fair bit of that um I think
we need to look at the the language
that's currently existing and determine
whether or not it is deficient and if we
do need to fix anything with that I
would further note that in this bill as
written if passed as is it would appear
that there are currently charter schools
that would more or less immediately
before forc to cease operations come j
July 1st which is something that would
need to be seriously worked out um in
this thank you thank you very much and
just to clarify uh the information that
I think represent luno and represent
belri are familiar with uh we did have
communication from uh the Department of
Education Caitlyn Davis and Diana Fenton
the attorney over there and I'll read
one paragraph right here it says we are
hoping that this bill could be retained
for a study committee as we have
recognized that there challenges with
the incorporation of charter schools
that need to be clarified in law but are
not not sure exactly what we should seek
we have been actively engaged with a
charitable trust unit at the AG's office
around this endeavor as well and it goes
on to speak to some of the issues
associated with 501 c3s so there there
is a a a a lot of work that we have to
do here and in in conjunction with the
entire Charter School chapter there and
so I think it's wise that we uh interim
study this and and work with the
Department trying to get some of these
areas
clarified further
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus representative beler
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Coro yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Alon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 208 Zer a and the last bill will
take up prior to launch herea
1610 this is this is standardized
assessment data for EFA
participants
yep uh represent C SC you're recognized
for a motion on
this uh10 I mooved to itl 1610 is there
a second a second representative dry
seconds that motion uh represent ccon
would you like to speak to your motion
[Applause]
please no represent dry yes thank you um
this bill fails the least restrictive
means tests for both homeschoolers and
EFA receiving families there already
assessment um
set standards set up in statute and this
would override
them further
discussion and there was some reference
to private schools in here um so there
there are some areas which uh need clean
up further discussion from the
committee Madam clerk would you please
call the rule on 1610 the motion is itl
made by represent cascad and second by
represent dry
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cor yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes we want to
representative Luna yes pleas PM
representative Heath yes representative
W yes representative Hall yes
representative Pony yes representative C
scen yes representative Damon yes and
chairman lad yes 20a Zer thank you
consent represent my yes thank you um we
we're going to take a break now but uh
when we met uh represent Myer earlier
there were several bills we said we were
going to discuss in the PM so we need to
be looking at those bills um um we had
some which were hold too uh but the PM
uh one of them I had down was
um another pm here was uh 10 10:14 10:14
and
15552 those were bills that we felt that
we would want to work with our cck
during the lunch hour there were other
holds but those were ones we had pm at
the side okay so we're going to break
and we'll take an hour break here for
lunch so we'll come back at roughly 10
minutes of one for those
that only read the big
hand yes we will be yeah
yeah represent Heath do you have a
second I'd like to talk to you about
what we did yesterday in
finance
[Music]
yeah remember Trac said
mil
e
ahe and uh continue our executive
session for today and we're going to
jump around a little bit on the schedule
right here i' like like to address HB
1592 that's the use of efas and
religious schools so it's
1592 just so everybody knows we do have
more Senate bills have come in so you
can add them to your 3in or now 4in
binders um or get a second binder or get
another binder yeah admiring your there
before before you leave and we need to
get them they're on the table and
they're crisscross so they're all
available they are not three hole
punched
okay so much for that huh okay 1592 is a
bill relative to the use of Education
Freedom accounts funds and religious
schools I Look to representative
cordelli for a motion uh thank you I
would move itl is there a
second a second okay representa leus
made the second and made by representa
cordelli uh represent cordelli you'd
like to speak to your
motion uh just briefly I I think that
this um disregards uh uh us uh Supreme
Court rulings and um therefore I I
cannot support it Prof
luus I just want to quote a dad he said
it's enraging to see people trying
anything to kill school choice and for
kids and to force kids to go to a failed
public school are there any other
comments from the
committee not seeing any requests Madam
clerk we're ready when you're ready the
motion is uh itl on
1592 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative he no
representative W no representative Hall
no Representative albone no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10 n motion go ahead represent
Miler move to OTP is there a second
for who made that represent whitcock uh
so we have a motion made by represent
Miler second by representative Woodcock
for uh
OTP further discussion from the make of
the motion I'm good thank you from the
SEC any other discussion not see any
Madam clerk would you please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pel no representative cor yell no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wot yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chman lad no 10
yes
10 okay so obviously representative cell
you'll be doing one and who's doing the
other represent Miler
okay okay the next one down we're going
to be doing is
1625 this is relative to school health
services so HB
representative pel you recognize for a
motion thank you I move in room study on
House Bill
1625 we have a motion made by
representative Pell uh to interim study
second by representative
Miler representative Pell will would you
like to speak to your motion yes thank
you um this bill um removes the
requirement for a school nurse to be
certified through the State Board of
Education um the State Board of
Education typically isn't in the
business of certifying nurses um this
bill
um yes so this re the current statute
requires that a nurse hold a license
issued by the Board of Nursing and
maintain a certification under the
Department of Education um a contract
nurs nures are not required to maintain
that certification Manchester hires
contracted nurses um quite a few
contracted nurses because they have
trouble finding nurses and if School
nurses would like to get a certification
they certainly can through a national
certification or through an accredited
college represent
Miler Is there further discussion on the
bill when you're
ready mam Kirk please call the
role Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell
no representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes repres representative wood no
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 y two
n is consent
okay is there going to be a Minority
Report no no okay just picked up on that
okay what was the count what was another
sorry 182 so that yeah 18 who made that
motion yes so you're doing that right
Katie
okay uh the next bill which we will
address is
1650 approval of alternative programs
for granting
credits
1650 16 oh you were
talking
1650 thank
you okay I Look to representa leus for a
motion I would like to move itl is there
a second second so we have a motion made
by represent leas itl and second by
representative cordelli this is
hb650 approval of alternative programs
for granting credits representative leus
do you want to speak to your motion
three quick points one there were no
examples of violation two businesses
already have to follow state
anti-discrimination laws and three all
this bill would do is limit learning
opportunities okay the second uh
represent Celli nothing further thank
you are there is there any are there any
other further comments representative
luno sure thanks um so um you know if we
if we are able to defeat this motion
we'll take up another motion of ought to
pass and I'll just save my comments for
I use my comments for right now but um
but all this bill does is um is seek to
require uh um that programs approved by
the state board as part of the learn
everywhere program comply with state
federal uh uh anti-discrimination laws
and have their own anti-discrimination
policy that's consistent with um with
the structure of
354a um you know unlike what we heard
yesterday from the uh from the
Department showing us a list of 800
organizations in fact this program only
has about 16 organizations I don't think
it's unwieldy or unmanageable to um to
to require those organizations to uh to
comply and um and further it does not
appear that any of the the learn
everywhere the approved learn everywhere
programs were lined up with uh the
example that was uh was given yesterday
regarding a builder in h Hinsdale so uh
so I don't think it would impact um uh
that student's particular experience so
so uh you know for at least those
reasons uh I would oppose the um the itl
and I'll look for another
motion further discussion from the
committee represent cordelli thank you
um I I believe also mentioned in
addition to learn everywhere there were
a couple of other programs and and one
that I had found out about um a number
of months ago um was related to CTE and
it's called work is
learning um so I think that there are a
number of uh students who are
participating in that I I don't have the
numbers there but um it's actually a
program I'd like to find out more
about further discussion from the
committee
not seeing any further discussion so
there's a motion on the floor to itl
1650 and the bill is approval of
alternative programs for granting credit
to
graduation Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corti yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no Representative woodcot no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10
days Mr chair I move uh to pass okay we
have a motion on the floor OTP uh made
by represent luno and second by
representative miler
represent Lun Luna would you like to
speak to your motion no I'm good thanks
represent Myer any further discussion
from the
committee Madam clerk when you're ready
we're
ready sorry just a sheet take your time
ran out sheets
okay U Vice chairman
Celli no Representative leus no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Corell no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Alon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
okay all right the reports are being
written by luno and and
leus all right uh moving down further
down the list here
um we're going to go to
1654 which is uh review of EFA service
providers
1654 again is a relative to review of
Education Freedom accounts service
providers and with that I look to
represent leus for a motion I move itl
is there a second
I'll second representative Noble yeah
okay so we have a motion made by
represent leus second by representa
Noble and that's referencing
1654 uh representative leus would you
like to speak to your
motion yes they would first off we've
found no examples of
violation second
off
[Music]
um this is going to the wrong people if
there are violations
of um any of
the
anti-discrimination laws whoever that's
happened to should go to the Human
Rights Commission that's what they're
set up
for
um the State Board of Education asking
them to review hundreds of VI of people
to make of um often outof State
businesses to make sure that they are
following this they are volunteers the
number of hours that they would be
working to have to go and and review
every single one because that's part of
it shall annually review all Education
Service Providers there are what did he
say 800 of them or something like that
and for to ask these
volunteers who are there to spend their
time doing something that would was
excuse me for a second I cannot hear
because of the chattered on that in the
table thank you go ahead to ask them to
do that is just totally unreasonable and
how they would make sure that all of
these outstate organizations follow
their own
um um what is the word I
want policy thank you follow their own
policies that's just unreasonable so the
effect I won't say that that was the
intent but the effect is that efas would
not be able to use many private entities
since the and just and
angry thank you very much represent
Noble do you have any comments nothing
further thank you are there any further
comments yes represent luno thank you
and just like the last bill um if we're
able to defeat this motion I'll be
making um an alternative motion uh to
pass but I'll I'll make my comments
right here so in in respect for time but
um but in fact um the committee did hear
testimony during the hearing yesterday
about a number of Education service
providers that had discriminatory um
quote anti-discrimination policies and
and particularly excluded um a number of
different um groups um
um that um uh I'm sorry CL um classes
that are protected under under
354a uh specifically um
lgbtq and um uh and um and so uh so as
such I think there is actually a
requirement for um for uh or a need for
uh for Bill such as this to make sure
that um that taxpayer dollars are go
when when tax or dollars are going
towards Educational Services that in
fact those services are complying with
with our state's um uh
anti-discrimination laws so thank you
thank you further yes represent leus I
will go ahead then and finish what I was
starting to say which is according to
our state laws um private entities are
allowed to discriminate based on certain
things and um by making it by this law
saying that they that efas then can't
use them you're
basically saying efas can't use these
private entities because the private
entities by our state laws are entitled
to discriminate based on certain things
thank
you
yes I would say on the reverse of that
that people that take efas that are part
of the G btq Community are then not
allowed to make those choices because
the school chooses not to allow them to
make that choice and school choice is
basically with the school not with the
student represent driver representa Dr
you've had your hand up several time
several moments here thank you Mr
chairman so I would just direct
everybody to 194 F7 the independence of
Education Service Providers specifically
Roman numeral 5 an education service
provider should not be required to alter
its Creed practices admission policy or
curriculum in order to accept payments
from an EFA the other four sections all
talk about how removed this education
service provider is from this it's
really the interaction is getting the
money for that service it's not the
provider that's on
trial further just represent LE you had
your hand up yeah I just wanted to reply
to the lgbtq because we did hear that
there were numerous as students who were
lgbtq who were bullied in the public
schools and the EFA is how they got out
of the public school to go to a school
that was welcoming to them a private
school that was welcoming to them so I
think using them as an example you
better look at the other side of that
too further discussion from the
committee yes represent
cascaden thank you I just um have to
point out I mean for me the reason I'm
here is to see what the impact on kids
is um we've heard a lot of numbers that
is a little bit confusing here yesterday
we heard that there were 800 programs
approved and learn everywhere today
we're hearing that there are 800 service
providers in the EFA
program neither one are true there are
actually 32 programs in approved
programs and they learn
everywhere and I had the list of service
providers it is not 800 it might be 80
85 I'm not sure but the decisions we
make today have a direct impact on kids
and we should be a little bit more
accurate in knowing what really impacts
kids and with that information this bill
should be on the books it should be OTP
further discussion from the
committee any further
discussion not seeing any hands up here
so we are ready to go ahead the motion
on 1654 is is
itl vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corel yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative d
no chairman L yes 10 y 10 n another
motion Mr chair I'll move to pass second
so we have a motion made on 1654 by
represent luno OTP and second by
represent
Miler represent
luno I think I'm good represent Miler
I'm good thank you any further
discussion from the
committee when you're ready Vice
chairman
cordelli Representative leus no
Representative beler no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
parel no representative Coro no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
and chairman lad no 10 y 10
days okay who's going to write it from
that end that represent
luno okay and then
okay we are now going to do
hr30 urging a robust climate
education
okay represent Bel do you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chair I would
move
is there a
second okay we have a motion on the
floor on H HR house resolution 30 made
by represent beler and second by
represent pel and the motion is itl
represent beler thank you Mr chair I'll
try to be fairly brief but um this goes
in very well with a a book that I'm just
finishing right now um abigil sh's most
recent book bad therapy which
incorporates some of what was heard um
yesterday uh regarding uh particularly
something called that's referred often
to as climate anxiety um there has been
at this point uh significant movement
within uh certain psychological um
fields to categorize this uh idea of
climate anxiety um it's something that I
think is actually probably legitimate
and I think based on what we have seen
both yesterday even though I wasn't here
at the time but also previously in other
uh in other testimony that children are
having extremely diff ult times around
their mental health and one of the big
reasons that we've heard is because of
they're worried about climate change now
I think first of all this is a very uh
politically charged issue I think that
we need to be keeping generally
politically charged issue at schools but
even if you don't agree with me on that
I don't think we should be inducing
climate anxiety in students by putting
more of this on them right now when
they're young informative and if this is
a real problem it's an adult problem to
be dealt with thank
you further discussion from the second
yes thank you um to first of all in in
addition to what representative beler
said I see this as a local control issue
it should be um taken up as part of the
science classes the school board can
certainly direct their Educators to
incorporate climate change and and I
certainly see evidence in my local
community on a regular basis of climate
change education occurring um however
I'm also concerned we had two bills
yesterday this one but preceded it was
the bill on masking and we heard
significant testimony about the fear
that was instilled over during the covid
um pandemic era and um I was
particularly concerned with the
testimony in using this um HR to instill
fear particularly of tickborne illnesses
with the um increasingly warm Seasons
that we will be having and for that
reason I will be supporting the it
motion further discussion representative
Woodcock thank you chairman I humbly
like I disagree with my two other fellow
uh Representatives here I do agree agree
with representative Bela talking about
that information is uh critical and
information is part of the the
foundation to provide uh a uh support
understanding of climate so I think this
opportunity hcr3 hc30 rather is just
doing that with Dees uh and and U Health
and Human Services providing a
fundamental Foundation based in science
that local as represent perel that local
schools have the option this is just
providing them options for information
uh and I do think it's critical that
there's no question it's raining soccer
river is up there's no snow for skiing
we can't f it it's happening all around
us folks I mean so it's it's uh I think
we really need to start addressing it
the gentleman yesterday who spoke most
of the people around here not you
Valerie most people around here have
gray hair we we Cause part of this we
can at least help solve it thank
you gray hair huh well
some don't have any I just wondering
where the hair is
here okay um go ahead rep cordello
thank you Mr chair so on line 21 it says
whereas such curriculum would include an
acknowledgement that human activities
have caused a crisis we are working to
solve today um not everyone believes
this and I'm one of them so I will be
voting itl I believe that these uh
children a lot of whom spoke having this
climate change anxiety I think it's
partially caused um by the um
promulgation of of things that uh I just
don't agree
with thank you further discussion
representative
Damon thank you Mr
chair I'm not quite sure where to begin
I find it sad that there wouldn't be
more unanimity on this topic there's no
cost to The Spill it's about
starting better conversation on this we
heard from I don't know how many two
dozen
students students brought the idea for
this bill forward to representative
Thomas pretending that climate change
isn't happening is not going to decrease
their anxiety you don't get rid of
anxiety by saying oh no it it's nothing
to worry about the adults will take care
of
it one particular student's remarks her
name was Sarah wiro
that I noted and I may be
paraphrasing but what I understood her
to say was students don't know what to
do and or they don't think anything they
do will be enough about climate
issues and the presentation from all of
them every single one that they want to
learn they want to understand this they
are seeing it happen affecting
agriculture
economy Lifestyles so many
things I was so impressed with their
work and their concern and I would think
we could support them in this representa
leus and then representative Tanner and
then represent
Miler if this was truly a non-political
bill and just
a what do we know what information is
out there what are different scientists
saying um I I think they should be
looking at what different scientists are
sing are there things well some of those
things they were talking about was just
pollution stuff which certainly we
should be dealing with um that's not
climate change that's pollution and
that's our local environment and we
definitely should be and always have
been should be dealing with that but
um the fact that it starts with an
acknowledgement that human activities
have caused a crisis and amongst
scientists there is a definite
disagreement as to how much if any is
caused by human activity and how much is
caused by greater forces like sunspots
like the change in the um not rotation
but evolution of the Earth around the
Sun based on planetary lineups and stuff
like that you know how much is based on
volcanoes how how much is based on um
the volcanic activity currently along
the rim of
the the
southern south of Antarctica
Etc and so to start from a point of view
a scientific point of view of which
there is difference on I think is wrong
I I have no problems I think it would be
great for kids to learn but they should
be learning what various scientists say
not just what the accepted by certain
people scientists say they should be
looking at both
sides and I have read many books
including by astronauts who have talked
about for instance CO2 the fact that the
Sahara Desert is shrinking you can see
it from space that's because of CO2 and
then to have somebody say we're all
going to starve because of climate
change when CO2 actually greens the
Earth and there's a lot of evidence for
that Etc the fact that there's
conflicting information theories Etc
they should
be presenting all of those not just
this number one here which is a foregone
conclusion and that's my objection is
that they're starting with a foregone
conclusion that has not been proven to
that is being
disputed
and um that's my real objection to this
thank you uh representative Tanner thank
you thank you I think um as a committee
we ought to be very cautious about
labeling students that come and talk
here as having anxiety uh issues uh I
don't think they had climate anxiety
issues I think they were uh pretty aware
of what was happening and didn't seem to
be well I'm not a psychiatrist so I
can't diagnose them um my other my other
question is uh HR could you this is the
first HR we've had in this would you
explain uh what it means as far because
I think some of the talk was about
curriculum and um I don't think this
requires curriculum in in schools or
anything I was wondering if you could
just tell us a little bit about what
happens to an HR why why an HR and uh
what the requirements are for that
please who are you speaking to oh well
seeing this as one of the first HRS
we've had
here um a house resolution does not
include it's not a bill so nothing is
statutory within this so if that's one
point you're looking for although this
bill does speak to
curriculum where if you look at the last
whereas it says whereas such curric
curriculum would include
and of course we also know that
curriculum is a responsibility of the
Local District instruction of curriculum
as that the statute specifies so but in
terms of whether this becomes statutory
no it does not where does it
go it it's just a resolution of the
house and quite truthfully I don't know
where it goes probably goes in a c
probably goes in a circular file
somewhere
um so we we've had bills of address
before I've
know I've been aware of the ones that
are congressional resolutions you know
to to send a letter down to the to
Congressional Delegation but I I just
don't know where it goes with the house
res and everything else um yes I I
remember that so represent Miler thank
you Mr chair yeah I think the the house
resolution is basically uh a statement
of intent on the part of the house as
far as what it feels about a particular
topic so and as the chair says it
doesn't go anywhere but it basically
says this is what we think is a body uh
so that's I wasn't G but that's a
clarification so my sense here as uh as
one of the senior members of this
committee um primarily in
age um you know it it's amazing to me uh
I don't know about when you at home but
when I see the evidence of uh tornadoes
going through Kansas Oklahoma or
Missouri or now U Michigan for all all
places where I live for 12 years uh or I
see the floods that are taking place in
California or the uh the 12T snow banks
in the sieras or uh the tornadoes and
wind I mean to me in my lifetime my wife
and I say why is this happening this
didn't happen
before uh and the the change of climate
around this country and the world is is
there there's no question about that and
it would seem to me that it's important
for this house to make a statement about
that and notwithstanding Whatever
anxiety you thought the kids have I
wasn't here when they were here but um
the point is they know this is
happening and they want to know why it's
happening frankly it's our
responsibility it's my responsibility as
a as as the old Geer in the group to say
what did I do that has caused
this uh and I take a certain
responsibility to that for that for my
grandkids and so for me the issue of
this resolution is merely a statement of
position for the house to say we need to
look at this and we need to make sure
that our students that are out there
have some sense of understanding of why
is this happening
and perhaps as a result of that
increased knowledge base they might save
this
planet because I'm sure it's hell too
old to try to save it right
now well let me talk because I'm
probably then the next oldest one right
um
so I can remember when I moved to Alaska
we' wake up some mornings and that's
above the illusion chain we were up on
on the Bearing Sea area we'd wake up to
minus 40
and and of course the folks up that way
said well just get used to it and yeah
it was hard getting used to it when you
go out and get in your Ford 150 pickup
truck that has vinyl seats on that are
frozen you sit them and they crack and
you have a heater block on the engine
and the engine's covered over with a
blanket and you can start it up yes
after you work on it a while but then
you can't get the transmission to move
at all uh so I I've been through that
but I'm also aware of other groups in
our world that have gone through to the
same thing and if we had the
representative from Lichfield that used
to sit on this committee he always used
to come forward and say but what about
the Vikings back in year
1000 and when they went to Iceland then
Leaf Ericson and Company come over
further and they go to Greenland and
then down through Lono Meadows in
Northern newfinland down long at coast
of Maine why did they leave Greenland
well because Greenland was getting
cold and so the climate was changing and
they had to go back to Iceland and back
to Scandinavia they never did really
leave Iceland but they did leave the
areas in North America and and uh
Greenland and that was because there was
a change in climate our world has gone
through these changes and it's cyclical
and so I'm not totally convinced yes I I
I see what's happening in the rainforest
down in Brazil and when I one of my
majors in college was geography and we
studied these things um and that's
man-made and we can stop that but some
other things I think are Beyond us and
that so there there all are Cycles so
I'll conclude that I'm I'm not really
absolutely sure that we can control some
of this some of this may just be a
natural occurrence thank you further
disc represent luno thank you very much
Mr chair and and you know I I um I I
appreciate your acknowledgement that
that some of it is man-made um and um
and you know something that's been
important to me when I talk with people
about climate change and obviously I
believe um that um that that what we've
been doing you know on Earth since the
industrial revolution has contributed
substantially to the the amassing of
greenhouse gases and and and carbon
dioxide that that has prevent that
prevents the uh the Earth from going
through its natural cooling but I also
recognize as as you've pointed out that
over the Millennia there have been
cycles that are sometimes thousands or
tens of thousands of years years long
where where there's where there are
Heating and Cooling events but to see
such sudden um um
uh changes in in the earth's climate by
degrees degrees
over over a period of a decade is
nothing like the Earth has ever seen
before and I think we've got scientists
that have that have that have shown that
you can actually see and I don't know if
it's in shell rock formations or in the
in the uh ice um U cores uh where where
the where there's been been melting and
um and cooling uh over a long period of
time it's never ever been in a short a
period of time right now but but going
back to what I what I what I like to
talk with people about uh about this
subject that sometimes reasonable people
do disagree on the on the C causes but
what is hard to disagree on right now is
the fact that the climate is
changing we might not know absolutely
positively sure
exactly what is causing it although I
think I got a pretty good idea but we
might not agree on the part but on the
end of on the end of it is there
something we can do about it and should
we do something about it and and I'm
hoping that reasonable people would be
able to agree on the first part of that
and the last part of that even if we
can't come to complete agreement on the
middle section the cause of it but but
should we is there something we can do
about it and should we do something
about it and I think that gets to the
core of of house resolution 30 uh which
is the last sentence in the bill
resolved by the house that the general
court and by extension the department
consider compiling and disseminate
climate act education curriculum so that
teachers may be prepared to implement
climate change education in their
classrooms and and it talks about
through all these whereases you know how
we can become more efficient what jobs
are available things that we can do that
maybe can slow mitigate or reverse um uh
what we've what what has happened over
the last decade or decades and um and I
think that's what that's what this Bill
gets that's what this resolution gets to
and I think that's what we heard I
wasn't here for the whole hearing
yesterday but we heard from so many
young people that that they just like to
be empowered to to do something further
discussion representative
Damon Mr chair I need a reminder on a
procedure question so the sponsor of the
bill provided an amendment
yesterday we have an itl motion so we
can't talk about the amendment am I
correct about that that's correct so I
would respectfully ask my colleagues
could we please defeat the itl so we can
bring the amendment
forward representative belard thank you
Mr chair I just wanted to offer a quick
clarification
um on something that was said earlier I
I certainly from my chair here would not
presume to diagnose a member of the
public offering testimony with with some
kind of a mental health condition I do
think that ABS in a good reason to
disbelieve them though when they tell us
something we should take them at their
word so when children come to this
committee as they have and they tell us
Point Blank that they are experiencing
climate anxiety and that because of what
they have learned about the climate that
they believe the world is ending we have
heard that in this committee that is
causing mental health problems to them I
think it's perfectly reasonable to take
them at their word on that and I think
we should respect
that yes represent MCD thank you
representative my primary objection with
this is that it is a resolution and not
a bill because the resolution is
encouraging both the department of
education and environmental services to
develop a curriculum but the language is
vague throughout the resolution to
include the title so we're en
encouraging them to develop a curriculum
but not outlining what the curriculum is
nor setting an appropriation for it
because again this is a resolution and
resolutions are not bills and bills set
Appropriations resolutions cannot to the
best of my knowledge so stepping away
from the climate issue I do not believe
this is the vehicle to move anything
forward but I'd like to tell the
students we duly note their concerns and
maybe we can work together in a
bipartisan way to bring something
forward that isn't a resolution or at
least not this one at this
time thank you are there yes
representative Drive you've had your
hand up a little bit here thank you um I
I would like to build on to what
representative McDonald said except to
politely point out that the Department
of Education or trans education
committee is not included in this
resolution at all and I believe this is
not the vehicle for it if you want to
talk about curriculum let's talk about
curriculum but let's talk about where
where the suggestion came from the other
day and I'm looking at the website of
the 350 NH youth team which uh Champions
Progressive climate policy and supports
candidates who do that so I'm
wondering if we're going to get a
balanced curriculum out of this
represent Leon represent woodcock
I just wanted to
address the whether or not we should
look at the amendment because the
objection is also in the amendment they
left one in and one is what we're
objecting to so I don't see that that
will help any represent Woodcock thank
you CH live um I go back to the basic
premise uh I was um completely uh uh
satisfied and happy and excited actually
yes they seeing students from Char
Schools students from Public Schools
students from school clubs schools uh
and school environmental science classes
come together from all over the state
saying please just acknow give us some
help here and all we're saying is let us
bring this forward and say Department of
Health and Human Services and Department
of Environmental Services because
they've done this before ask please help
us to have government do something give
them the option to start working for us
to provide this information it doesn't
say any school district has to accept it
it doesn't outline what particular pie
they're saying here we see a problem
we're the coming youth of of the country
we came to the place that's supposed to
be helping democracy education commit
education that's all we're asking for
and so I think it's really simple it's
it's and and as you said Mr sheer when
they ask where do it go from here it may
end up in that circular file but at
least we've done our part and put it
forward to say yeah we acknowledge kids
you're asking for help we're try to put
you give us a direction we'll try to
follow it thank you let me respond a
little bit to this that within this bill
or this
resolution if you look down on some of
the uh statements which are made on
lines 24 on
downwards when they say including
elements of the Industrial Revolution
fine that's that's great but when they
they start talking about deliberate
misinformation campaigns by big
oil it start you know I'm a kind of an
oil guy that comes from
Alaska and and gas C companies to
misinform the public about the effects
of climate
change I think this is clearly a
political
message and that that that bothers me
that then we're as the as the house
we're being asked to pass a
resolution that's saying that
deliberately Miss information campaign
liberate misinformation campaigns
regarding fossil
fuels uh I I think that that's you
know putting this on it is certainly not
fair and balanced as represent dry was
trying to to say or
state earlier with our comments
representative
Damon if I could just respond to that
concern Mr chair the amendment changes
that language and specifically says a
balanced historical back background on
the innovations that led to the
Discovery and use of fossil fuels and
goes on and lists other things but I
think I think they did recognize that
the way that that was um phrased was not
appropriate um and to me balanced
historical background that's exactly
what we should be providing students on
every
topic further discussion represent
cordelli Ju Just to follow on that um uh
I also see on page two the local case
studies um do not look balanced to me
and uh I certainly if you wanted to have
a balanced approach you could take a
look at the failure of offshore wind
leasing um off the coast of New
Jersey um and uh up above that I'm not
sure what environmental racism
is further discussion from the committee
on the bill here or on the resolution
yes represent cascaden just have to add
my two cents you don't
mind um I just have to relay this
information so a little over 10 years
ago I started my doctoral study the
first book in the first course was
called futuring and we had to look at
all of the scientific
evidence on this particular topic that
was over 10 years ago now so obviously
it had a tension then
um after spending over 40 years 180 days
a year with hundreds of kids every
single day many have anxiety over a
number of things write down a climate
anxiety if they're going to miss recess
I have anxiety if the notch is going to
close um I think we're overthinking this
we need to step back and look at the
message these kids are trying to give I
don't want those kids to say in five
years yeah so and so on that
committee denied it we're not giving
them permission to change anything we're
giving them
validation for what they believe is
occurring and they will continue to
study
it I don't know why we're just keep
beating
this I was support the kids anything
kids do bar surpasses what adults could
do I I I remember coming from your neck
of the woods up there in runford and and
Berlin and you had Brown Paper Company
weighed the Oxford and my father in-law
who was an engineer in nor Eastern grad
used to say to me Rick don't worry about
it the smell is
money
and represent cordelli um thank you I
certainly enjoy seeing the kids here but
um you know I I don't think that every
um opinion from a group of students
brought to us requires us to um fall in
line and pass legislation that they're
asking for um and the same goes for even
some of the um bills put forth by uh
fourth grade classes about um the state
Jumping Frog or Jumping Frog license
plates um you know I don't think you
know we need to follow all that
direction just because it's kids um you
know you know maybe we should get some
senior groups in here to uh pres present
opinions also they're already here
they're
here boy I I walked into that one didn't
I represent Damon you have your hand up
again I
do so I'm sure we don't like do a straw
pole but I appreciate that there are
concerns about the specific language in
this bill in fact it's a lengthy
resolution with a lot of
specificity so I'm wondering if there is
an
appetite bipartisan I've heard several
folks say they would be willing to work
on
this is there some way for us to not
vote on this today and collaboratively
come up with an alternative simpler
resolution we do have a motion on the
table
so with that what I'm going to do is go
through the taking action on that motion
we we're running out of time here and I
I I realize you know uh your what your
request is so if there's no more
discussion on this we're going to move
forward with the
motion that was put forth uh which is to
itl
hr30 mam clerk would you please call the
RO
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
Representative wooda no representative
Hall no representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad
yeah pardon me
your uh yes 10 y 10 days
so motion stud um we have I'll recognize
represent cordelli for a motion yes I'd
like to move um based on uh suggestions
I just heard a motion of inome
study is there a
second rep represent Terry
made the
second further discussion on the inter
room study from represent
cordelli no no represent
Terry um I have nothing additional to
add thank you any further discussion
from the
committee yes representative Woodcock Mr
chair I want to be clear before we vote
and lost this I not going to support
inter from study I think it's important
that we uh continue working on this
today and the come will vote thank you
further
discussion all right uh repres Madam
clerk would you please call the role
Miss chairman cordelli yes yes
representative leus yes representative
Belcher no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes Representative corello no
representative Terry yes representative
Miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Heath no
representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad
yes eight y uh 12 n is there another
motion represent
representes and is there a second
represent Miler so we have a motion for
OTP on hr30 made by represent Damon and
second by representative Miler further
discussion from the maker of the
motion um I want to bring forward the
amendment might as well do it so it was
circulated yesterday it is amendment
number 9368
um I do not have multiple copies because
I didn't expect to be doing this
everybody have
it um so it
changes uh line
22 I'm sorry let me just make sure I
have this
right
yes
no why 24 to 28 I'm sorry I had the
number wrong changes line 24 to 28 Roman
numeral number two on the first page of
the original D is
changed um and it changes the concluding
resolution lines 28 to 31 is replaced
with language that includes the
Department of Health and Human Services
and the Department of Environmental
Science
services
second
me the am second
yeah okay so we have a motion for the
amendment what's the amendment number
again 0936 H okay
0936 and it's made by represent Damon
and second by represent Miler uh
represent Damon would like to speak to
your motion
please I think most of what needs to be
said has been said and we can go to a
vote when people are
represent
Miler represent Pell yes thank you I
just want to point out that um line in
lines 13 um when the on the amendment it
leaves out the Department of
Education represent tner
when we did the Civics Civics did that
go through the Department of Education
or was that an independent the Civics
curriculum are you talking about the
textbook no the Civics model curriculum
that's that came by way of a bill yes
under studies right but was that that
wasn't through the Department of
Education that was through a committee
right an independent committee no that
bill specifically said there would be a
half CR a credit in the Middle School
Credit and half Credit in the U High
School for the teaching of civics um it
didn't change the the uh the uh academic
standards for social studies at all and
it didn't lay out a specific curriculum
either right and that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about a model
Civics curriculum that we in the past
we've had people that have have put out
model curriculum that people can use or
not use that hasn't necessarily been
developed by the Department of Education
isn't that correct
I and Civics is one of them I'm not
recalling a model curriculum in Civics
we had a model curriculum which I had
gotten from the state of Ohio or the
Holocaust and the Holocaust we were
working with the Holocaust Center over
in Keen State College it's not through
the Department of Education necessarily
but that that there's a commission or a
committee a commission working on that
right now right that's that's
that's what I mean just the fact that
the Department of Education is not part
of this resolution is Not Unusual it's
it it's happened before it happens with
the Holocaust studies it happens I
pretty sure with the Civic studies um
but but with with with with the
Holocaust it's also a part of adequacy
we have that underneath as one of those
topical areas a substant criteria for an
adequate education Holocaust is
specifically
mentioned
they don't have to use the curriculum
developed I I have not seen a curriculum
on the Holocaust come out of that group
yet so there's nothing brought back for
consideration either as part of the
minim standards for public school
approval are the academic standards I I
haven't seen
it representer Cornell I don't remember
yesterday any of the presenters
mentioning the Department of Education
when they were presenting the um hr30
they said the Department of Health and
Human Services and the Department of
Environmental I think that's in the
original but I there were two of us that
weren't here and I don't think
representative Heath was here at that
time either we were all busy down the
end of the hall dealing with that
Finance uh yeah represent I was just
merely pointing out that that was one of
the differences between the original
bill and the amendment I didn't need to
go down this road I just wanted to point
it out
okay yes represent Woodcock not the beli
just the represent pel's Point um it's
clear uh that the department of
education does not have the staff to
continue to update curriculum across the
agenda uh as was pointed out yesterday
by the commissioner talking about math
and science and math in English 2014 the
most recent time they did it um and we
all know not anyone's fault they just
not a staff they to do it so it's not
surprising the do is not in this as
curriculum developers anyhow cuz it's
just subject thank you just just to tag
on that a little bit yes the curriculum
department at the Department of
Education has basically been raped uh
over the years we've just lost Personnel
over there and it's you know I've been
in districts that have more curriculum
staff than our department of education
has in the state the way we've developed
curriculum is through task force that
are brought together they come down and
work with with the Department of
Education and then make a recommendation
at the end of
that I appreciate that thank you
yeah further discussion we have an
amendment in front of us a motion for
the OTP of the
amendment any further discussion on the
amendment yes represent
beler thank you Mr chair I'll be brief I
just wanted to say that the amendment
opens online well number one but line
four an acknowledgement that human
activities have caused a crisis we are
working to solve today I fundamentally
disagree with that I don't think it's
true that we have I think it's vastly
overstated so I can't support
this okay so we have a any further
discussion on the amendment it's
0936 Madam clerk Vice chairman cordelli
no Representative leus no representative
Belcher no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no Representative corello no
representative Terry no representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
Nays over back to the main bill main
resolution right now uh
hr30 as it was
introduced any further discussion
representative Terry understand we're
back to the somewhat uh problematic
language of this uh of this resolution I
recognize that it's a resolution and not
a bill but I have to vote against this
because I find that it has a high degree
and and a disturbing degree of
pmic further
discussion not yes
OTP on where you I talk in you the
because we we started out with the
amendment so did she did she make the
amendment the original OTP Amendment
there was really no
OTP moved do we have do who made the
motion on the OTP it was represent Damon
right what represent Miler Damon
yeah that and then and the same thing
with the
amendment yeah so okay we just missed it
over here to my right okay so we have an
A B A resolution on the table as it was
introduced now uh
hr30 and the motion is
OTP further
discussion Madam clerk Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Belcher no no no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
Corell no representative Terry no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wot yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 y 10
n all righty who's writing the reports
here represent
Damon and it'll be OT yep a a with 0936
yeah you want a yes A
or that's
okay the amendment would be attached we
doing tomorrow yes it's it would be in
the package there you would have otpa
yeah and and the other side's
itl all righty the next bill going down
the list here is
1014 this is registration of high school
students to
vote 1014 okay Uriel said she'd write
the report for this Uriel write the
report for
[Music]
is there am circulated there is one
there it there there was one early one
which was
0538 is that the
amendment I thought there
wasn't okay we will take a well
represent d goes upstairs and gets that
we'll take a break here when she comes
back we'll
continue
so
get going here uh we just have a a few
bills which going to remain doing today
we've done 11 bills so far today out of
the 34 that just leaves 23 bills left
for this session in terms of house bills
um we have um I'd like to have a little
bit of a discussion on this voter
registration or voter bill but I'd like
to do that as the last thing we do here
today in case we got to get any more
information um uh so we're going to jump
and do one bill and then we're going to
slide in that um I I've said to some
folks we'll be done by o00 today yes we
will be uh so that folks have to be at
other meetings which I know some have so
let's just jump and go to
1552 and then we'll come back to 10:14
and have a discussion on 10:14 without
anything on the table here no motions
made 15 what
do you want to make the that was your
bill
right yeah you were going to make yeah
and then I and then I'll put the
amendment in okay I'll
make yeah
yeah and I'll second
it
we
14 right I I thought we said we were G
to hold that before no I
had oh you did I thought yeah you right
down in
there hoping we
all
we were
talking says
oober okay we have a little change in
plans here we're going to while we have
some folks here in the audience that can
help us out on this uh we're going to go
back to
1476 that's the bill dealing with char
School memorandum of understanding
that's where it says this you know all
all charters have anou with the their
resident District which sends care you
know takes care of the special ed
services at the charter and theou is
effective start at the start of the
school year and the change in this I
believe was November
one um the question we have is is the
November one date what we want or do we
want like an October 1 date where the
enrollment is collected Jane do you have
a second you could come up if you have
any of that information available for
us yeah hold
on we want to take advantage of you
while you're
here since you've been here all
day good afternoon thank you J you're
you're familiar with theou process
correct yes and
so can you just give us a brief
rationale why we put at the start start
of the school year vers November one and
why November 1 maybe vers October 1 sure
so every school district has been
charged with um getting anou to the um
public charter schools and the
department of Ed has given us a template
um to do that um originally July was the
um deadline to get that all signed
sealed and delivered during um the
summer often times um there there aren't
a lot of folks at the charter schools um
and so there's been a few challenges in
terms of meeting that deadline um moving
the deadline to the fall would certainly
help I think the charter schools as well
as the leas um in getting um the not
just the signatures but getting all the
essential information into those uh M
us so in terms of the these children or
students which are coming uh it's just
at a start right now and of course we
don't know what it really looks like at
the charter school there may be a number
of kids that moved in with
IEPs what what's the rational having
Waits so long from the start to November
one vers let's say to October 1 when the
school submits its enrollment data to
the state department I think it's when
kids are enrolled at least this is my
understanding in in the charter schools
it's up to the parents to to notify the
charter school that the child has an
IEP um and and then get that information
commun communicate that to the school
district sometimes the parents do notify
the leas so there at times there's a a
gap in terms of even knowing um that a
student with an IEP is even at a charter
school the district isn't necessarily
notified right away um and I'm sure
there's a variety of reasons for that um
but this would you know putting the
deadline up would give ample time to um
you know ensure that everything in
thatou is is signed sealed and delivered
and that includes everything from who's
going to deliver the services to how
much it's going to cost when it's going
to happen who the you know what the
credentials are of the individuals
sometimes in the summer you don't even
know some of that information yet um so
it would give folks the time to get
those details
right represent Luna thank thanks very
much and and thanks Jane for being able
for sticking with us all day on this
when it comes to the um the Theus and
the delivery of services and yeah I
understand that that that you know um
students with with
IEPs every I is you know is a little
different um um but as far as the mou
are concerned and delivery of services
do those change dramatically from year
to year between um a a school district
and a and a and a charter or delivery of
most of the services already defined in
thatou yeah I don't think there's a huge
amount of change because it's not
student specific in theou it talks about
who's going to deliver the services when
it's going to happen how much it's going
to cost um because there's a variety of
ways in which it can happen the school
district can send someone there they can
contract with someone that's independent
to go there the charter schools are
sometimes providing that services and
charging the schools so it's you know it
it it's dependent upon the school and
the but it's it's it's the agreement
between the Lea and the charter school
it's not about each specific kid it's
the IEP that really dictates the child
specific information thank thank you
we're going to have a number of
questions do you mind taking them sure
go right ahead represent
leus given that that's the case do you
think a school do you think the mou
could be done by October 1st rather than
November 1st
I think it it's possible we still are
having difficulty getting some of theou
signed it's the the the um you know it's
up to the Lea to get these signed and
people are doing their due diligence and
documenting attempts um and it's only a
small portion but I think giving folks
you know more time is is just going to
make it um more efficient for both the
charter school and for the Lea
follow up yes go ahead I'm just
concerned about the students and whether
or not they'll actually be getting the
services while they're waiting for that
and that's why I hesitate that's why I'm
asking what the earliest we could put it
as to make sure there aren't students
being left behind well as I mentioned it
the IEP the leas are obligated it's
their responsibility regardless of
whether or not the mou signed I mean
they've got to provide those services so
this is is just dictating like who's
doing it and how much it's going to cost
uh those kinds of things so the the Lea
is really held responsible um by state
and federal law to be providing those
Services whether or not theou is signed
or
not I I'm going to read one one thing
here before we move on um the
methodology under the fiscal report has
a sentence the last sentence and it's a
little bit of concern to myself I'll
read it with the current difficulties
all districts are having with finding
staff and service providers this would
make funding staff finding staff and
service providers for charter school is
extremely difficult near impossible
after the school year starts ultimately
any impact this bill may have on local
school district expenditures in FY 25
and Beyond is indeterminable I'm not
worried about that last sentence so much
is why why is it why is it so difficult
for the sending schools to the charters
to have this all figured out prior to
the start of the school year like as I
mentioned sometimes the districts don't
even know that the kids are in in the
charter schools um unless the parent
notifies that they've made this decision
and they're going to um place the kid
there so um a lot of times you're still
hiring folks uh in the summer and to
determine you know who's going to
Charter Schools to do the services and
or or is this charter school going to do
it if they're closed during the summer
and there's all kinds of implications
that could delay and make some
difficulties repes cordelan then
represent cascad thank you um yeah I
think that maybe the methodology that
chairman lad pointed out is the reason
um uh Melissa white from the Department
said that it's uh possible that no
Services could be provided until
November one um which would be the
deadline for the uh um theou um
well that's just my speculation but that
that was her testimony it's possible
that no Services could be provided till
November 1st um and I'm not sure if it's
because of theou or the difficulty in
finding staff after the beginning of the
year as I mentioned the leas are
obligated um and there are there are
circumstances when you can't find staff
but that's true in our Public Schools
also in our private special education
schools in the world of special
education it's a critical shortage area
we're just talking about that a little
while ago it's very very difficult to be
filling positions so there may be a
lapse in programming for for for kids
but it's not specific to Charter
Schools yes represent cascad uh thank
you just um when I looked at the
November deadline um I was thinking of
the practicality of all of this to me it
this makes sense for the simple reason
that um October 1st is that Statewide
data collection for enrollment right and
so then that gives if there are students
in a charter school that nobody knows
about until that enrollment is reported
it gives them a few weeks to like
Scramble for aaff develop the IEP look
to see what or not develop the IB
whatever they decide as a team because a
team
decision um and I wasn't so worried
about kids not getting services in the
beginning of the year because an IEP
from the previous year would not have
lapsed yeah so that's I mean I'm just
thinking of implementation of that date
yeah we like everything neat and in
place by opening
day um but where you have to look at
your current schedule of students who
are receiving
Services you have to now develop a
system to see what what else needs to be
provided over and above that I think
that's a time so represent cascad would
it be better to have the annual mou from
November 1 through October
31st in thinking of the
practicality I think it would work
better
um yeah that's what I was thinking when
I read this I mean it might not be the
end all cure all but so how do we take
care of the kids which are coming
in that may have an IEP an active IEP
from
some other District other than that
sending district and the services isn't
going to be provided and quite possibly
and violation of federal
law I I don't see it that way I think if
there was a student that came into a
charter school with a significant need
for services their first call is the
district
school I mean maybe it's not I don't
know and then that kicks things in
action and again theou isn't student
specific so when a child moves in yes
you convene that team you've got x
amount of time to do that and and you
know your will say you know oh we've got
a teacher that's going to the charter
school and this is when we're going to
provide that service or you know the
charter school is going to do it in
charge us represent cordelli uh thank
you but it's possible that that student
is coming from a different school
district for which the charter has noou
so that would require them to put
everything in place after the start of
the school year very possibly theou has
to be between the resident district and
the charter right not the resident
District of the kid the district which
the charter is part of it's where the
child lives so so you could have several
districts that's right GL is right yeah
yeah the charter schools are going to
have M us from many districts
okay
represas so explain to me what would
happen if a kid comes from a district
with an IEP in place from a district
that has noou with the charter school
and comes into that Charter School say
shortly before the start of
school the sending District yes is
required to
provide for that
IEP but when it gets down to the how
this is
done if there's no agreement to who
provides it or where or any of that how
is that IEP I mean what exactly is going
to happen how is that IEP going to be
provided for if there's no agreement as
to who's providing it what what actually
what is the the actual what happens when
that kid shows up so I'm not sure if I
understand the question but I'll try so
you're saying that a school district um
let's just say
Manchester um doesn't have anou with the
sunshine charter school and a kid moves
into Manchester with an knife a kid
moves from Manchester public school to
that charter school with an
i what happens so no agreement as to
who's going to provide the
services sorry there's no agreement as
to who's going to provide the services
yet how do the services actually get
provided to begin with that's my
question well the Lea is obligated to
get thatou and if the charter school is
refusing or they can't come to agreement
what I'm seeing is legal is getting
involved um the department of that has
been clear that they don't get involved
they're not mediators they don't when
when there's
disagreement they don't get involved at
all it's up to the charter school and
the Lea to work it out however um they
want to do that but that doesn't stop
the child from getting their services
because the Lea is obligated by law to
do that whether or not the mou is signed
or not so that's my question is how the
I they get the services if nobody has
agreed to who's providing them the Lea
makes that decision I mean they they'll
say we're going to send our speech
therapists until you agree or um you
know they've got to do it whatever way
they can okay thank you the laa doesn't
speak to Susan Jones the the the student
it speaks to the services the laa is
providing to the Charter
whether you're going to do it through a
contracted service or through a delivery
service directly from your bank of
teachers at the Lea or whether we're
going to transfer the kids from charter
school back to the ELA for delivery of
service there there's a lot of different
methodologies within statue allow us to
do this I thought the mou was more Broad
in dealing here's how we're going to
provide the speech therapy services to
this school and we'll send the speech
therapists over there on Mondays and
Thursdays or whatever
is pretty broad I mean it doesn't say
the name of the service provider but it
was say it says that Manchester is going
to provide all of the special education
you know within that charter school or
they're going to say we're going to
contract with this organization to go
into the charter school or the mou might
say the charter school is going to
provide the
services here's their credentials here's
how much we're going to charge um and
here's how we're going to work with you
to monitor that progress so you're right
there's there's all different ways in
which an mou could be
written represent Miler so we have the
date here of November 1st there's
nothing that would uh prohibit a school
district from developing that prior to
November 1 exactly so this is just an
out this is an outside date that you
have to get done by uh secondly I think
if uh if if my child has an IEP and I'm
going to go to a charter school I
already have the IEP does that help to
facilitate uh that process of the trans
the transition from my child going to a
charter school and yet receiving the
same kinds of services that I would have
in the Resident School
District
so could you repeat the question so I've
got an IEP y from Hopkinson and I want
to go to Mary Smith's charter school
down here I've got the IEP the services
have been provided by the resident
School District I'm now going to be
going here wouldn't I be receiving
similar Services if with that IE TR with
that IEP transfer to that charter school
yeah the IEP won't change the team will
convene and just review and make sure
you got the credential people and that
everything's in place and if I may Mr CH
go ahead uh and and the team you're
referring to would be those who are from
the resident school district and now
some new personalities that would be in
the charter school that would be
responsible for making sure that the
resident school district is meeting
their obligations through the IEP is
that correct yes it's a combination of
both staff thank you further
questions of
Jane Becky you've been a special all
your life do you have anything to add on
that well we know you've been a director
of
it uh thank you good afternoon uh Becky
Wilson from New Hampshire school boards
Association I'm happy to try to clarify
any other um questions that maybe Jane
hasn't addressed other than our
understanding from the school district
perspective and the Schoolboard
perspective theou is really an
administrative it's talking about
billing who's in charge of billing what
you're how you're billing certain
Services who's responsible for setting
them up supervision Etc it's not a
student specific issue we were providing
services to students at Charter Schools
long before anou ever existed
so yes represent Terry questions occur
to me and I I don't know the best person
available please answer one or
both uh wondering where the where the
date November 1st came from as the the
date originally uh proposed why October
November 1 instead of some other day I'm
assuming that it wasn't arbitrary but
that there was some rationale for that
and I guess I'm really seeking the
rationale for November the 1st the other
question is uh I need clarification on
the memorandum of understanding are is
the memorandum of uh understanding
student
specific so that if you had two
different students coming from two
different school districts you would
have two different memorandums of
understanding or if you had if you had
two students coming from the same school
to the same PRI charter school would you
only need one memorandum of
understanding or because the needs were
different for the two students you need
two memorandums of understanding which
lead which prompts me then to ask if if
it's prompt if it's defined by the
student and the student needs then why
not language such that no later than
four weeks after enrollment rather than
this arbit seemingly arbitrary date of
November the 1st and if you can remember
all of that I would appreciate it
because I'm not sure I can I'll do my
best to Jane can certainly fill in it is
important to me thank you thank you um
I'm I'll go backwards because I think
that might be easier when this bill was
originally brought to the committee the
Catalyst for the bill was that yet
public charter schools take students
from multiple districts it doesn't
matter where they live if the if the kid
shows up there and the parent enrolls
them at a charter school a district
cannot place a kid at a charter school
the parent is enrolling them that it's
potentially possible that a charter
school could have realistically 10 or 20
districts and that the districts that
are the districts of residents are to
provide the services for are responsible
for the service provision for those
students and if you're working with 10
or 20 districts they could all have
different ways in which they wanted to
do that it was causing a lot of
confusion in terms of billing and things
like that administrative tasks so theou
was meant to try to create a template
that could be consistent that districts
and Charter Schools could use together
to try to create some expectation of
consistency for those kinds of things
like rates for different providers ERS
of services who was qualified to provide
them in different situations Etc this
contract that you're talking about for
student specific needs that's the IEP
that's that is the student specific
piece theou is really a broad to Jam's
Point earlier attempt at clarifying
responsibility and rates and uh tasks in
terms of who is filing certain paperwork
Etc so that things are between the
districts and the Charter School uh what
was the first part of your question on
November 1st so so may I answer uh so
the first question was can you give us
any information or provide any insight
as to where November 1st came from in
the original proposal here I me what so
you why then as opposed to some other
time such as four weeks within four
weeks after enrollment or Sub sub thing
thank you for the question
representative I think originally in can
help me if I'm not remembering correctly
when this bill first came it there was
no date I think it just said within 30
days of enrollment and the problem that
I think people were concerned about with
that is that because a parent is
enrolling the child you might not know
within 30 days or it could be summer and
school may not be in session so there
could be some challenge in terms of
clarifying um some of those things
because people just might not be aware
it's also not common in any District or
public charter school that the first 30
days of school the first 45 days of
school everybody is sort of getting up
and running so even in your local public
schools there's some things that are
still sort of being figured out in terms
of day-to-day
operations um that would be similar at a
charter school for example and so trying
to have everything lined up before kids
get off the bus on the very first day
might not be realistic so there was sort
of this conversation about trying to
find The Sweet Spot of what was the
right date and I think that November 1st
seemed like you have been in school
about 60 days your other reporting
requirements would have already been met
so all these things that districts are
already doing about enrollment who's
going where and making sure you have all
your ducks in a row would be clean so
your data collection would be clean when
those muus would need to be signed go
ahead so to representative lak's
question just to be clear because the
IEP is following the student the Lea is
I guess is is obligated to provide the
services so the memor memorandum of
understanding whether it's October 1st
or November 1 is not any kind of
impediment to the student receiving the
services it's rather a
formalization of that which is going to
take place with respect to the two
districts that are involved correct
thank you for the question in theory yes
and the only reason that it might be
confusing is again it's a parental
placement so districts are not always
involved from the get-go so the
the date aspect of it as long as the
parent alerts the charter school that
the student is coming in and the student
has previously been eligible and has a
current IEP that communication should be
happening between the charter school and
the District of residents and they
should be figuring that out regardless
of theou or at the latest they're going
to know the first day the child shows up
at the school as long as someone
discloses that to them yes thank you
yeah um I I we have a question for you
because we've just had a communication
from Melissa white who's ill and
couldn't be here and the question was um
that represent leus had asked and here's
the response and there is no sanction
for the charter school not to sign
theou so some of them are not signing it
so is this issue we're looking at larger
than a date is it the the whole thing
came about as I recall because Services
weren't being provided to the charter
school or the charter school and
couldn't agree with the Lea
and how these Services were to be
delivered where or where and so then
that we had this conflict whether it's
one side or the other doesn't sound like
there's any way we have to say there
needs to be anou in
place and it takes a long time for these
mlus I remember we tried to get anou
between Dartmouth College and the
municipality of Hanover that took us
three years with the county attorney
getting
involved so I I'm a little bit concerned
whether November one is really going to
fix anything
well our association has been meeting
every month with the um Charter School
Bureau with the Charter School Alliance
and the Bureau of special education and
I would say the vast majority of charter
schools have worked hand inand with the
leas in getting um those mou signed I
believe it's just a small amount of um
schools where we've got a little bit of
a challenge in terms of not getting
signatures in terms of the date November
I to to Becky's point it gives everyone
um a chance to figure out schedules and
do what's best for the child I'm also
seeing that some regions of the state
are working together because we're
having such a hard time finding people
um and they're charting who needs what
services at what schools so that they
can work together and cost share and you
know do their absolute best to get these
services to the kids in the charter
schools so I think everyone's trying
really hard and I think you know theou
has given some consistency and framework
and with anything you know that's new I
think we're going to have a few speed
bumps along the way and we we do have a
few Charter Schools where um they're
seeking legal guidance and um there are
some conflicts there but overall it
seems to be running fairly
smoothly well you it's represent leus uh
go
ahead so
overall kids are getting the services
they need one way or another is that
what you're I would say yes I mean even
in our Public Schools we're short on
staff and there are times when kids
aren't getting Serv
but we know we have to make them up okay
thank
you represent cordelli thank
you I for one um would be hesitant
moving forward I'm sorry thank you um
would be hesitant moving forward today
on this um it seems to me this
uncertainty um you know especially with
the director of instruction saying that
uh there are instances where that mou is
not getting
signed and um that there um might be a
lack of services being provided to some
students um and you know she mentioned
um you know there's no penalty for not
signing
theou um so I I I for one would say that
we need to look into this a little bit
more before um moving forward on it
today and I I'm going line with that um
you know I'm all for doing something but
you know I have a daughter who's a
special ed teacher was a special teacher
in bath and having deliver Services
outside trying to coordinate that
schedule with the receiving school and
the sending school was extremely
difficult and I don't know if they ever
got anou in place
so I I think we need to do something
here but I don't really you know whether
it should be you know from uh a a school
rather than using a school year we use a
a period of time which I mentioned
representative cascaden earlier from
maybe November one November one to
October
31 um uh that might be good but also I
I'd like to have if we can gather more
information from director white uh the
information that representative cordelli
just spoke to is that is this working if
it's not working can we do anything to
try to get it to work I know there's a
teacher shortage there's teacher issues
in terms of even providing all the
services within the laa itself more or
less transporting and going somewhere
else either transporting to the laa or
from the LA to the the charter so Becky
and I were just talking it's important
to remember that the services in the IEP
really are very different than theou so
if a child isn't getting services that
may or may not be um connected to theou
and in most circumstances it's probably
not it's probably a kid specific issue a
staffing issue um probably not anou
issue well it could be a contractual
issue it could be a a transportation
issue it could be related to
scheduling at the different facilities
the availability of a a staff member to
get there or not get there um and I
think that's gon to even if you had anou
that's going to happen sometimes yeah
yeah if if I'm missing something here um
let me know but but it it would seem it
it seems from what we've heard that
theou defines the responsibilities in
the relationship between the the
District of residents and the charter
school that the that the student is is
is attending and those responsibilities
would
include um where services are provided
how services are provided um um
how much services are going to be build
for and obviously the the ultimate
responsibility based on what I'm hearing
for the provision of these Services
rests with the District of residents not
with the not with the charter but we've
talked about in this committee as long
as I've been on the committee and I'm
sure much longer for senior you know
members of the committee um have have
talked about providing services in least
restrictive environment and and I think
theou probably seeks that that out and
from year to year
unless you know Charter a is now taking
a a student from a district that they've
that that that's new to them so and and
I agree that that would happen um that
would happen for most for for most of
the IEPs that are in place theou is
continuing on for years year after year
and having thatou in place is really
important for a new District they could
rely on in you know look at anou from a
district that's already working with
that Charter and say hey here's what
here's what the other schools were were
we're doing on here but but from a
practical standpoint you know saying
that this is going to be negotiated and
developed during the summertime when
when yeah I mean school districts
special education directors are year-
round employees at a school district so
they're around but there aren't a lot of
employees around at at a at a charter
school that that having this done for
for by November 1st which gives the
whole month of September the whole month
of nove whole month of October to make
changes to theou makes a lot of sense to
me um and and you know
ultimately the the students IEP is going
to to define the resources that need to
be um in place theou defines the who's
responsible who's paying for it and how
much are they
paying so I you
know the important thing is to get it
done and and and you know I you know we
heard the other day how important it is
to get inside a school district and I
think if we were to be in a school
district for the first 60 days you'd
realize how quickly November 1st comes
around and how much work there is to do
between September 1st or you know right
after Labor Day or right before Labor
Day when when schools come in and then
you're at October 1st you're reporting
out enrollments and wow then you're in
November 1st and before you know it
you're into the holidays so um so
November 1st is a great deadline to have
for um um for contracts so
so I I you know and and this also isn't
the last stop for this bill I know we
got a lot of bills to exec it'll go to
the Senate it'll it'll have additional
hearings whe whether this needs to
wiggle to October 1st you
know you know I think November 1st is
probably the right date in terms of um
uh bringing it on I I think we could get
this get this done today represent
cordelli um
I I would definitely like to see
something done with this um I think it's
a good vehicle to
um resolve any other problems that there
might be um you know in terms of what um
director white said if there are
problems in getting a charter school to
sign theou if they they are holding
things up for some reason you know maybe
there and she said you know there's no
Penal for them not signing theou which
does you know include contractual things
rates and Etc which is pretty important
um you know I would like to see us you
know make a little take a little time on
this um you know I agree it could be
amended in the Senate but but there's
also no rush to doing it today we have
time so I would um very much like to
hold on to this and see if we can uh
chat further with uh the parties
involved
um including um the director of charter
schools maybe the Charter School
Alliance um and the director of
instruction and special ed I'd also
remind you too that you know in on
behalf of the charter schools many of
them may be working with 20 or more
districts so giving them the time um to
schedule those meetings with the leas um
I think they would benefit also from the
time um you know if you if you give them
that November deadline on behalf of the
kids and getting you know giving them
ample time to work with the elas and
coordinate is is also something to think
about right and I I think in my mind the
most important thing and the most scary
thing that I've heard is that it's
possible that no Services could be
provided until then um and that's where
I'd like to make sure that we have
covered so that services are provided to
the student as soon as possible just
keep in mind that the services are
outlined in the IEP um and they're
totally separate from
theou um and so the whether or not you
have a signed mou the district is
obligated to provide those services and
and that's what's happening in those
places where there's not ass signed mou
it's still going on I mean there the
services are being provided to kids and
the districts are just documenting their
attempts to get those signatures on the
you that's not quite what director white
is is saying to me on
online the other concern which we have
if there's no mou it's difficult for the
local re Lea to develop what
expenditures they're going to have in
their budget upcoming budget uh and
reflecting exactly what has been said
here is difficult for the school
districts to budget those expenditures
appropriately if there's
noou and if we're hearing that there's
some not having mou
then I I'd like to know why there
there's no us I'm I'm not concerned the
date November one yes but it's led to me
worrying now that there's other issues
that are associated with this mou that
may need a little bit of attention and
I'd like to get more information from
director white Melissa so that we could
make a a a better decision come maybe
next week when we're we're meeting this
is not going to have to be taken up
today but but it's unfortunately we've
had 107 bills we haven't had the time to
put into this and keep in mind I don't
think that you know the date has nothing
to do with the unsigned M and I I do
believe it's a very small number ofus
that aren't signed in terms of our
conversations with the department and um
I think that's you're right those that
those small Pockets have to be ironed
out I don't necessarily see that
connected to the date
but I see this possibly as being a
vehicle to try and maybe help out with
some of those other questions which we
have without making modifications but to
add something on they saying hey there's
got to be a little bit of accountability
here there's got to be anou signed if
there's a a student over here or your
providing Services over there well get
it in
place kind of makes legislature look
like why did we pass this stuff to begin
with don't answer that don't answer
that
represent Heath thank you Mr chair I
really am reluctant to um I it sounds
like things are getting into place I am
concerned that you are thinking in terms
of a penalty and I would hate to see any
kind of a penalty imposed on one of our
Char schools I'm not looking at a
penalty thank you no I'm just trying to
get some more
information any other questions
for Jane or Becky
thank you very much thank
you meet again white will be here miss
white will be here yeah she's not sick
yeah yeah she's she's out because of
that today and she's been communicating
with us yeah so we we won't take action
on this today we don't have uh anything
on the floor we do have an amendment yes
um or do we have an amendment on that
one no there's no am excuse me I'm
thinking of the other one I'm thinking
of of uh represented Damon's bill so
what it is we we've completed those a
number of bills today and everybody
should have a copy of the agenda which
is a draft agenda which shows you what
we're going to be doing
here well our clerk has to be out of
here in nine minutes no I'm good don't
do it I can for 30 is my dead drop dead
deadline
so
easy I'd like to hold
it we're we're we're gonna hold 1014
we're not going to do it right
now look at it Mr chair I'm just gonna
distribute the if you want to discuss it
yes but we're not going to take any
action on it right now let's do that
let's discuss it but not no motions on
the table I won't accept
them so represent Damon would you please
explain what you have there on 10:14
relative registration of high school
students to
vote yes thank you Mr chair so 10:14 on
high school students to vote so the
amendment that will come around is
amendment number
one2 this is not the same amendment that
you have previously
seen however it
is um very similar the only difference
between this and amendment number
538 is that the new Amendment removes
private
schools so both
amendments take
out
line8 in the original
bill that line read or reads providing
access to an assistance with filing
registration applications so both
versions of the amendment remove
any
um request in policy to provide access
or assistance with the actual filling
out of
applications um so essentially the bill
with either amendment is simply to ask
school districts
to that way
you
sure here's there's one more right
here'll do it
again everybody good I didn't keep one
here it's fine
no okay
so amendment number
one2 is the one I'm requesting we
consider each School District shall
adopt policies to promote voter
registration it's just about saying have
a
policy policies
may not shall may include collaboration
with the town or city clerk and the
supervisors of the checklist to conduct
voter registration at high
schools completion of voter registration
shall not be a course requirement or
graded assignment for
students policies shall include
informing students of state requirements
for Boer
registration so no private school no
actual filling out of applications not
unless the school chooses to collaborate
in that way but it's not required in the
policy it's just about making sure that
every single public high school student
is aware of how they become a voter
that's
all so this bill this amendment is
saying to conduct registration of Voters
at
school no sir that is not
correct what I'm reading on lines four
and five to conduct voter registration
in high schools it says may include
collaboration with the town or city
clerk doesn't mean they have to they
don't have to do that they may do that
okay all they have to do is have a
policy that promotes student voter
registration it could be as simple as
the policy
saying in civics class we will tell our
students what documents they need to
register to vote and who they need to
contact to do
that represent
Belin thank you Mr J I guess this is a
question to help clarify because I I
noticed it specifically prohibits graded
assignments but is there such a thing as
a non-graded assignment or just an
assignment that is attached to a
competency and not graded or something
to that
effect I would defer to the folks who
are Educators to help me with the answer
to
that representative Tanner answer that
representative
Tanner thank you I think that it says
that it shall not be a course
requirement um that means that
or a graded assignment that you could
have work work um books or work sheets
that people fill out but it wouldn't be
something that was required or
graded or passed in or passed
in just to further clarify that though
it does leave open the possibility that
teacher could assign it say write this
up on the board say that you you have
we're asking you to do this but it's not
graded or anything else can I respond
respond yes I would say that if I I
would never uh as a teacher I would
never say that that way it would be U
like a worksheet that's passed out and
say this is not required or graded um
look it over you don't have to turn it
in I mean that's that's how you kind of
do if you were going to if you were
going to do something that you're afraid
that they're going to do that's that's
about the level that they would do
yes repr yeah to me
um we've talked a lot in this committee
about Civics
education
right isn't this the end of civics
education like how to
vote and get
involved I mean this is so simple to me
as part of whatever curriculum I'm going
to be teaching is I'm going to be able
to tell students here's how you go out
and vote and stop telling who you should
vote for or how uh what candidate you
ought to vote it's just go out and
register and
vote to me I I don't know why we have a
problem with this if in fact we believe
in what we've already done in the whole
area of civics
education yes representative now thank
you I'm just wondering how necessary
this is
18911 ran numeral 1f says the um and
this is under the civic's um
requirement Roman or letter F says the
role wait sorry let me read the
introduction a school district shall
develop and offer the US and New
Hampshire history government and
constitutions course and Civics course
under paragraph 1A at minimum the course
shall include instruction in the
following areas and F is the role
opportunities and responsibilities of a
citizen to engage in Civic activity to
me that would include
voting further discussion representative
Hall thank you Mr chair um this is we
have a problem and that problem is we
have over
16,000 18 year olds in New Hampshire
16,000
15.6% of them registered to vote in 20
in the in 2223 at the close
15.6% nationally that's
30.6%
double of the 18y olds who are
registered to vote 83% of them do vote
so we need more kids to register to vote
so they can engage in it be involved in
Civic engagement which I believe we all
support um so I I I think this bill
supports getting more kids to register
to vote informing them and having them
do
it further discussion on this amendment
represent
Damon so I think you all have heard me
mentioned previously that I'm mentoring
a sunap high school senior on her senior
project which is on local voter
engagement and she's a bright fun
interesting young woman she texted me
this morning has the bill come up yet I
said no but I think today um she just
went to her town so she goes to school
in son but she lives in lemster to
lemster's school meeting last week for
the first time that she had attended um
the annual event and her takeaway was
there are so few people participating
and so few of the people who are
participating understand what their
level of responsibility is and how to do
this she's totally
motivated to work on this and and this
bill is so a model of what we want we
want I think all of us when I say
we to have young people
appreciate the opportunity to
participate in democracy that's all this
is this is just a very simple invitation
to the students to make it clear to them
how do you become one of us people who
vote representa but the way I read this
in actuality it's not just providing
information it's also perhaps providing
the opportunity with respect to the May
collaborate
with the uh town uh or city officials in
actually conducting the registration and
being and doing it on site
traditionally uh I have understood voter
registration uh schools to provide
education to students information but
not necessarily to actually lead them to
the point where they're actually in this
instance registering to vote uh this was
something in my life experience where my
parents actually uh saw as their role as
parents to impress upon me the need to
register as a voter what we're doing yet
again is we are replacing parents with
the school and saying that the primary
responsibility de facto may be shifting
to the school to register s students to
vote at the age of 18 rather than to
have it be a personal responsibility or
one that is fostered by the parents in
the parental role so so um I'm I'm
concerned about that if you strike that
one sentence I I could live with this
but uh putting the school in the role of
actually uh taking the place of the
parents is troubling to me thank
you representative
Damon I think those of us who have the
great Good Fortune to have parents or
grandparents or other people
who guided us to as representative Terry
just spoke to become voters are
immensely
fortunate and that is not
everyone represent Hall thank you IEX
I'm not one of those I grew up in a
household with two parents lived in
lived in New Hampshire for 60 years
never became citizens so if you and they
never could vote so if you think they
encourag me to register to vote
not true thank
you representative Bel then representa
Woodcock thank you Mr chair I I heard a
statement made that we have a problem in
this state and in this country regarding
some of the voter statistics but I would
like to hear any reasonable rationale
for why it is within the purview of this
committee to tell any person any citizen
who decides of their own free will that
they don't want to vote that they are a
problem Peron Woodcock thank you
chairman Le I don't think this this bill
forces youngsters to register to vote it
gives them the
opportunity um and I'm not sure
represent Terry is aware of this since
he just joined a couple weeks ago but
students in high schools all through New
Hampshire have been doing this and
schools been doing this for a long time
in multiple schools where at the end of
the year there's the registar from the
town will clerk will come in and have a
booth there and some signs up and if
students want to vote to give the
opportunity to make them more convenient
like we often bring food to the school
to make them more convenient for them or
textbook sometimes to make them more
convenient for them if they don't have
them at home this is just another
another supplement as an option for
youngsters uh to do
that thank you many many many years ago
we had a bill which dealt
with tuition rates for kids to go to UNH
Keen or
Plymouth and we allow and it dealt with
the kids which had grown up in New
Hampshire gone through Elementary Middle
School high schools in New Hampshire but
their parents had come over after World
War II and were not
citizens the kids did not learn that
they were not citizens because they came
with their
parents until 18 age 18 and therefore
they did not get instate tuition at unh
and UNH has a policy that you have to be
a citizen of this
state so what about all those students
which are coming in because we can't say
to a student wanting to walk in the
doors at those schools in Manchester you
can't enroll unless you're a citizen of
the United States your enrollment would
probably decrease a sign significant
amount of students so what about those
students which are in this class who
want to register vote but I can't
register vote because I'm not a citizen
is that
discriminatory I would suggest it's a
wonderful time for them to find out in
the opportunity how to move on that's
why it's Civics and then they go back to
their parents and we had one student
come in who was Val Victorian of the
class who was not a
citizen that couldn't get instate
tuition
UNH you know who it was I thought I
heard somebody say the Damon Mr chair
with respect we would just be
providing the facts to both the students
who are eligible to register to vote and
to those students who are not eligible
because they're not American
citizens and as representative Woodcock
noted those latter students could then
decide they want to become citizens or
not that is obviously their
choice we're not we're simply providing
the facts we're we're not doing anything
discriminatory
informing about that I I I agree with
what I heard on the other side of the
room here to my left where I think it
should be a part of what we're doing in
our Civics education we should be
teaching kids that we want them they
live in a democracy and it's we're as
strong as a democracy as our
participation in it and so that should
be a part of and being a voter is very
important but to take it to the next
step and do the registration at the
school
rather than doing it through the process
which has been established I agree I
think we're taking something out of the
hands which really belong in the other
party the parent and and uh I think the
school has an obligation to teach this
in our Civics
classes and that's where I'd far prefer
to see this type of language put
underneath the studies of civic
education represent hall and then
represent wood thank you can I just
clarification did you actually just say
that you disagree with any of this voter
registration going on in schools right
now with all the towns that do it that
you disagree with that that that should
not happen I believe registration should
not occur in schools I believe
registration should occur at the
registration booth in the clerk's office
or with the supervisor checklist we need
to be teaching the importance of of of
being a registered voter at school but
that practice of registering them I
would prefer to see outside the school
that's shocking to me yeah repr
Woodcock thank you um I'm thinking as
you're talking about the youngster who
rebelled Victorian was um not a citizen
and yet we've put in place for every
single youngster that they have to take
the immigration Naturalization test no
matter where you come from if you come
from America take an naturalization test
take an immigration test cuz we said you
need to do it and we're doing it here
we're just talk about voting simple
simple this case and that young would be
perfect can test sh and get us voting
registra at the same time represent
Terry yes uh thank you uh I'm not going
to uh raise my voice and be impassioned
at this point but I I am somewhat uh
concerned that um I'm I'm envisioning
myself at the school at the age of 18 on
the day that the uh voter registration
uh might take place under the provisions
of this of this uh Bill my social SEC my
my social SEC my social studies teacher
is an avowed Democrat and has let all of
us know in the class during the year
that that he's a Democrat and this in
fact was the case when I was in school
back in the day I'm a Democrat we have
peer pressure with kids we want to do
what your friends are doing and they're
all going to register as Democrats and
so I registered as a Democrat now I'm
sure that'll bring joy I see the smiles
on the side on the faces of my
colleagues across the a they're really
thrilled and but I'll tell you this I
come home hey hey let's have some order
here now he has I have the floor repres
repres excuse me I have the floor so I
come home from school that day and I
announced to my parents that I became a
Democrat at voter registration at school
which they didn't even know about was
taking place that day uh because all of
my friends registered as Democrats and I
wanted to be cool and and therefore be
one of them and uh by by the way my
teacher is is a Democrat and I'm sure
that'll help my grade as well this is
the reasoning of an 18-year-old and it's
not an unreasonable reasoning of an
18-year-old and anyone who would suggest
that it's not a a possible reasoning of
an 18-year-old has no idea how an
18-year-old reasons and has no idea what
goes on in the minds and in the hearts
and the lives of children of that age
and you can shake your head all you want
but that's the truth thank you thank you
very much
we began today by talking about how we
are set a historic record for the number
of bills that have come through our
committee and one of the things that I
frequently tell people is we have too
many laws there is lots of duplication
in the education statutes already this
bill this bill is covered in
18911 Roman numeral 1 f it is covered in
18922 it is covered in 189 923 we do not
need a
fourth piece of legislation that tells
student teachers teachers puts the
burden on the teachers that they need to
do yet another thing when we've already
covered it three places in the
statute represent
Miler thank you Mr
chair I believe this bill does not
demand registration
it merely States how do you do
it number
one secondly in regarding to the charge
that teachers will influence uh how
individuals are going to vote totally
disagree with
that several years ago many years
ago I was involved in the development of
the 26th Amendment to the US
Constitution you all know what that is
right 18 y old
vote at the time that we were working on
that and lobbying for it the charge was
made that oh well you're going to have
this influence Etc you know what
happened when the registrations came in
and the reports after that came in they
basically registered the same way their
parents
did interesting isn't it wasn't what a
teacher said but it was the impact of
the family that's how they voted so
those who were concerned about a flood
for one party or another party totally
was dismissed by that because they voted
how their parents did in my sense is
that's the same thing that's going to
happen here it's not going to be based
upon
peer I mean I I I am I am
stunned by this
conversation and we have spent so much
time talking about Civics education as
representative Woodcock said we demanded
that they have to take the
naturalization test put another burden
on students to do that all we're saying
here is here's how you do it guys go do
it we're not bringing it into the
schools some may decide to do that but
that's a local decision by a school
board this law does not this proposal
does not demand that at all it just says
here's how you do it
folks I I I'm
stunned I'm sorry Mr chair I just don't
know I I would suggest we move to vote
this
get this off the Record we know where we
are and let's do it as soon as
representative hold it I'm through with
this conversation we don't need it
anymore as far as I'm concern are there
any is there any more discussion on this
bill right now yes represent dry
sorry thank you and and I want to
address what you just said thank you
very much instru on how to do it
representative Pell gave a um a couple
of of Statute Illusions in her talk just
a second ago but she didn't read what it
says this is about distribution the
State Board of Education is hereby
directed to distribute copies of the
State Constitution and election laws to
all teachers of history and Civics in
the upper grades of elementary schools
and to teachers of US history in Junior
and senior high schools to be used by
them in instructing their pupils
relative to the laws governing election
and voting it's already there and it's a
command distribute this teach it
done yeah I agree with you represent
Belcher thank you Mr chair previously I
spoke a bit to the amendment I didn't
want to go too much into the underlying
bill but there was a
question why should students not be
registered at school and I'd like to
take that question so there's two
different types of discrimination the
first type of discrimination is very
obvious it is discriminating against
people the second type of discrimination
is not nearly as obvious but it is just
as pernicious and that is discriminating
for people and unless we're going to
bring this to all populations not just
schools but the 70-year-old couple up in
the rural part of my dist who has to
drive 20 mi to register it is unfair to
discriminate for one population against
any
others representa whitcock yes thank you
just just a point of information uh
representative Heath went because you
said 4:00 time limit and that you were
not going to vote that's right we are
then that's I already mentioned that
so yeah we're after four o'clock
represent C cordelli thank you uh just
following up on uh representative dr's
reading of that statute um I think that
had come up at our initial um meeting
about this and I think the statute dates
back to the 1930s 1936 maybe if I'm
correct uh
ah um yeah it's that age thing um uh so
I checked with the chair of the state
board and the uh Commissioner of
education and and that had been lost
somewhere during the years they were
unaware of it they said they will start
doing it right
away any further discussion because
we're not taking any more action so with
that we're going to close down today's
activities here
and see everybody
tomorrow